[Music]
greetings podcasters welcome to the
church of what's happening now
the church of what's happening now is
brought to you by onyx.com
go to honor for all your supplement
needs
whether it's shroom tech
alpha brain with 100 money back
guarantee hemp force protein mct oil
if they got it it's unbelievable because
i know aubrey goes all out to get the
best products available to you go to
honor right go to honey.com right now
and take a look at the great selection
of supplements they have if you like
something you see go to the box and
press in church booyah
get 10 off delivered right to your door
number two
listen to me and you know i love you and
i respect you it's august it's july
we're about to go into the hottest
[ __ ] two months of your life you want
to go out and date and mingle you want
to be confident
that's where hellotushy.com comes in
okay
you don't want to walk around with swamp
ass nobody wants to do that you're
sitting there going what's hello tushie
hello tushy there's a portable bidet you
snap right into your toilet you got
dirty ass you scratch your ass you sniff
your fingers it smells like a goat sit
on the [ __ ]
sit on the [ __ ] hello tushy and watch
all your problems go away right now go
to hellotushy.com right now hit it lee
go to helitosh.com last church and boom
and get ten percent off all right
listen your life will be a hundred
percent better with a bidet trust what
i'm telling you kick that muley
here we go
here we go
what the [ __ ] you think you're dealing
with [ __ ]
the church or what's happening now
july 5th
the fireworks are gone the only thing
you got is the rage left in your [ __ ]
heart top suckers
church of what's happening now coming at
you
kick that muley i want to go [ __ ]
deaf today
what the [ __ ] you think you're dealing
with
the luckiest day you ever had
was the day your dog got hit by a car
hit it
here we go
oh yeah
oh [ __ ] drop that xanax
here we go
sounds like dean del rey and heath
[ __ ]
mauricio alvarado
dean delray
my jewish nephew
it's a church of what's happened now
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
house tonight that [ __ ] was great
dean del rey
stand-up extraordinaire
sneaking up on the scene and my main man
mauricio alvarado photographer heavy
metal [ __ ] genius
and just all-around [ __ ] great guy
welcome to the show what's up also my
main man the flying jew
fresh from his [ __ ] uh conveyor belt
sushi oh you don't like that that's like
though it's like the perfect place if
you're a stoner
to go there's no server interaction at
all that place sucks you don't like it
yeah that's gross fish oh come on no no
i told you conveyor belt fish like i
told you dog if you pick it
it's terrible no it's just terrible
it's just i told somebody else and they
were like i told bert he's like does he
not know that place is [ __ ] around
there's eight thousand plates you don't
know where i went
listen
it's good
it's downtown right no where is it it's
in the nice area by the jews in west l.a
yeah they have them in downtown in
little tokyo but they i don't i i don't
go there i go to where the jews are i'm
west l.a for sushi when you have the
best sushi
state right here oh no this is what i
deal with no you just like this is your
favorite place no there's two phenomenal
places in the valley yeah but you drove
to west
l.a conveyor belt sushi because [ __ ]
i'm sure yelp was involved or
something was involved here i went to a
place once where it came on bites boats
instead of a conveyor belt it's like
water and it's in san fran it just
floats up to you oh it's mine it's nasty
unbelievable
nasty fish on the conveyor it's like the
fish jumped onto the boat yeah and they
have they have it so you can just order
it on an ipad and they make it fresh so
you don't have to wait for the conveyor
belt sure
sure they don't they do wait what do you
mean should they do it one on the
holiday weekend on a monday on a sunday
ooh look at that
it never ends it never ends with this
house of horror let's take lee to the
good spot he wouldn't he would he would
die
if you took him to a good restaurant he
would die yeah
him and they pick garbage on purpose
they throw a dart what's the worst place
we could go to and where could we drive
to the really waste of [ __ ] time
i was telling birthday and i go bert
i'm doing a human experiment yeah i got
like a human experiment and i watch
people you know i watch everybody and i
think i
i think college people lately like this
new last two generations
they're done
dumb as rocks not dumb done because they
bought into something
him and the agostine are the same age
the agostino makes less money than he
does you got to see the places the
agostino goes to just on a hunch yeah he
grew up in the valley i give him that
but he doesn't go on any safaris nothing
like that he knows where it's consistent
yeah it's consistent
it's all you know i'm saying like i
that's all i've ever tried to do for you
is just
eliminate the hype and the [ __ ] and
you get the best available to you that's
what i've strived for
my whole life the beauty of my life is
as dumb as i am and uneducated and
felonies is i never bought into the hype
of nothing
nothing nothing it was always my
battlefield my playing field and this
ain't gonna work for you
since i've been 20 like i didn't
understand and i've had my hard-headed
moments as a young man that's why i
ended up in prison you know what i'm
saying yep
but those little hard-headed moments
land you in a different prison
when things are simple right in front of
you but you choose to make them harder
and whatever
that comes back to bite you you go the
long road not now but later yeah we goof
on it and i think about lee and i go
what's he doing
like how did he get this in his head
like ventura is right there santa
barbara's right there but he went to
pismo beach
yeah yeah like it never ends it's like
every time he says something like i just
go oh my god
and i giggle in my head
because it's not even a hypothesis
you're missing out pismo beach is great
it's an energy
educated yes yeah and it's not even an
educated guess
they let somebody else do the guessing
for them
so why live why be alive yeah
what are you doing lee i don't do
nothing that's cool like i don't give a
[ __ ] alcohol is yeah if somebody sells
me something that's cool i don't want to
go there like remember for a while on
sunset they had the naked lady sushi oh
yeah downstairs yeah go eat your [ __ ]
sushi or something chick's stomach
do i want to do that
i go two minutes on colfax i sit at the
bar i don't bother nobody i get the
philly roll the [ __ ] uh a couple
pieces of albacore and i'm out of that
tip-top my goo yeah cause i ain't got
time to waste i don't have time to go to
the capitol of [ __ ] sushi here in
california yeah to go all the way to the
west side
the worst area to west side yeah yeah
four pieces of [ __ ] it says little japan
on the street name if you if you go to
that street that's why you're going in
japanese yeah that's why i go there i
went there for sushi it took 10 minutes
it's right next to the 405.
if you're missing out dude
it's little japan over there they have a
little they have a nursery for flowers
that little japanese people they take
care of flowers it's beautiful they they
have restaurants where they only have
japanese on them it's great little japan
or little tokyo well no it's like little
tokyo is like i think it's actually
called little japan too i just call it
little tokyo that they have that in
downtown i went there once it was okay
but there were lines everywhere
i went down to west l.a there's parking
tons of parking
it was it was great it was fun what did
you hear about this restaurant i looked
i won't
he hates yelp so but here's you use yelp
i usually please he doesn't go but but
he gets yelp whatever his girlfriend
says no whatever the boss says and yelp
the boss says um
i just used it because where else are
you supposed to find the conveyor belt
sushi place i just typed in conveyor
belt sushi i found one and i used to
work right next door where did you hear
about conveyor belt sushi in the first
place i've i've uh first of all one of
our good friends went there when i don't
know if it was that one i didn't get a
text back but uh and then i when i moved
out here unfair when i went out here i
read an article our good friend becky
went to one of the same thing with the
ipad oh yeah yeah right
i don't know to me it just sounds like
it's just process sushi
is it fresh they make it fresh and then
here you go i don't ever get it no i
mean i don't know
probably
the ones on the conveyor belt probably
could go around
brother
oh disgusting
7-eleven sushi you ever see that
sometimes i walk in i see 7-eleven sushi
and i go are you [ __ ] kidding like
who would even tempt that lee wouldn't
it no i would if i wouldn't have met
leigh he would have been a 7-eleven
at least fighting back tonight look at
him because he's he's he's uh
what is it called
uh what's this slandering this is
libeling my name slandering on your
taste
yeah have you have you ever gotten sick
from when you've never won oh yes he has
no i haven't wholesale sushi on laurel
no i didn't i got sick because you saw
me i saw people running out of there one
day i said where'd you go for sushi over
there i saw people running out of there
like their [ __ ] was on fire
that whole
the hindu place yeah they got the
[ __ ] uh what's the other plate the
cookies
yeah they got like a they have a
macaroon place yeah macaroon place yeah
noodle something that's horrific over
there that whole corn i got a story for
you i had phil sousan on the podcast
from ozzy he's the bass player who wrote
bark at the moon
and uh
he goes hey man i opened a sushi place
um
you gotta come we'll do the podcast
there and i go and it's on woodman and
ventura right
and i go in we eat i go this place is
[ __ ] phenomenal he goes i've been
eating sushi since 76 with first tour of
japan and [ __ ] you know hanging out with
jimmy page he ate sushi learned all
about it he stole the greatest chefs in
town he opened this place
i started eating there then i go on the
road i come home about four months later
and i eat there again and i text him and
i said
hey man uh food's kind of different
tonight you know and he texts back and
goes oh
my partners [ __ ] me over man they sold
it don't eat there anymore as i'm eating
it was completely different you can tell
the difference and immediately i won't
mess around with that stuff at all oh no
you can tell unless i have blood that
goes in there and eats and comes out
yeah i won't go into a sushi place it
was insane blood like somebody i trust
like blood yeah yeah like i go there all
the time and go there for eight years
it's tremendous have you uh been to the
fisherman's outlet in downtown on south
central no that's like a landmark they
said it's tremendous it's amazing it's
some of the best uh seafood you can have
right leeway it's great it's a business
conveyor belt no no no
they got like a roller coaster
some kind of roller coaster we can ride
while we're eating the fish no they make
it fresh
you guys are just missing out you the
future's coming yeah we're gonna be left
behind
the future's coming why are they gonna
have servers why are they gonna have
right they have everything you wanna and
you wanna add to that you wanna be a
partner not to have a server to take
jobs from more americans than what they
lose there's nothing that's what you
wanna lose take away take away more
human contact than what we already have
to get [ __ ] in the ass by life more
than what it is just walking in there is
a [ __ ] disgrace
because you're taking money out of
somebody's [ __ ] pocket
these [ __ ] idiots think about the
future but they've never thought about
the whole thing yeah yeah half of these
products that we have today you've never
thought them the [ __ ] out like i've said
it a thousand times the cell phone
camera
that guy i hope he got caught eating
some [ __ ] little boy's [ __ ] in
taipan with his own [ __ ] camera
design you know what i'm saying wiped
out yeah wiped out the film industry
single-handedly yeah nobody ever thought
this [ __ ] out here yeah so what the
in private 7 000 jobs what about all
those kodak uh like development places
you pull up in your car
what about what about kodak kodak went
under or it's pretty close to going
under they have like one somebody bought
them on their back happening remember
that you'd pull up yeah the hat the
little little house and you go here's my
[ __ ] i'll see you tomorrow it's funny
last night maid was on oh yeah that's on
craigslist
the other guy they're in new york and
they're walking through the streets and
they're taking pictures with puffy combs
he just dropped the box i love that they
went back and they take all your nudes
yeah like whenever you took a picture of
a nude you all excited together i got a
picture of your [ __ ] yeah and you
went back and they stole your [ __ ]
news yeah yeah yeah i used to have a
buddy man
you would go to uh weddings and they
would have cameras uh those those
cardboard cameras there take your own
photos of the wedding then the the
people would develop them you know like
here's our wedding you know people would
do that it's like a theme and he would
go in the bathroom just take pictures of
his dick and stuff and put it back on
the table then they're getting the
wedding photos back it's like dick pics
hilarious
oh man i was thinking the other day when
i was growing up as a kid because like
this it's just gonna have it's not like
you can't stop this stuff from happening
when i was a kid i remember with my mom
we would go to return cans and there was
an actual like a people in a room at the
grocery store like when you got the
cards and they would count the cans and
hand them a box of cans and and then
give you they'd actually give you the
money i think if i'm not mistaken right
now it's a machine it's just like it's
it's
it's gonna happen it's why there's uh
like those
boards at mcdonald's now nobody's gonna
have money to buy anything because they
don't have jobs anymore well they're
actually talking about like a bunch of
like the really like uh the fate like
mark zuckerberg and all those people are
talking about like a universal uh
what is it called income or something
like they're talking about testing that
out now because welcome to the machine
yeah they're gonna have there's no
there's not any jobs anymore like that
you're either gonna have to make your
own business or
like i'm a [ __ ] robot yeah pretty
much people are anyway so
it really doesn't matter so you're the
[ __ ] king of concerts now what is
your position exactly you're a freelance
photographer yeah i started off uh
freelancing uh for you know doing
photography for a couple of publications
in la there's one called mix down and
then there's one called switch where um
it's a mexican publication because a lot
of bands don't go to mexico or you know
latin america a lot of you know big
bands do go they play photosol down
there like metallica yeah metal bands
metal bands big bands stuff like that
but a lot of
smaller bands like medium sized bands
usually don't tour down there and
there's a lot of fans that love music i
heard you i heard you uh a conversation
you had with the guy rudy talking about
how mexicans are really into the metal
music
they're into music
it's a heavy metal scene yeah latin
latin america mexican people they're all
into music and they're deeply they love
it and you know with all the trump stuff
that's kind of going on i feel like
maybe they're i don't know if they're
scared or with the visas and stuff like
that but just bans aren't playing down
there and you know i you know take
photos and send them down there so they
could you know see what's going on
hopefully the bands could go down there
they get inspired or maybe you know the
fans maybe can come up to la because
that's the closest area but
yeah how old are you 27 and then what
your dad get you into it or something no
my dad and my parents you know they're
all into you know the spanish music
those bookies stuff like that you know
traditional stuff but uh i started with
the beatles uncle mine said hey you
should get the beatles one album when
that came out they're all the first one
first one started getting into the
beatles got really obsessed so the thing
with me is i get really obsessed with
bands
so i learned everything about that band
learned everything about the beatles and
then moved on to like santana got really
obsessed santana credence move on just
different bands different bands and then
now i'm going back listening to bands
that fall in the cracks you know there's
yeah there's the bigger bands but then
there's also smaller bands that you know
yeah like cactus [ __ ] like that stuff
like that uh there's a band called
gentle giant yup
that actually opened up for black
sabbath at the hollywood bowl when black
sabbath played there
and they got the worst treatment there
you know people throw firecrackers at
them there's a bootleg audio of that
i've been you know them trying to play
their music and he was just throwing
firecrackers but general giant is an
amazing band
hopefully i'm trying to get them the
amoeba they haven't done anything in a
while but but yeah i love music i love
going to concerts like i go to i do
photography i do interviews
um yeah i see it at the shows when i see
it recently i think the last thing i saw
yet was either craft work or maybe like
black savage yeah yeah hollywood bowl so
you go to all the concerts on a press
pass yeah pretty much okay so i go take
photos and then just write reviews about
it um the last thing i saw was iron
maiden they played san bernardino
over the weekend yeah over the weekend
they were great um the last thing also
uh roger waters i saw roger waters he
did an amazing show he played you know
welcome to the machine animals stuff
dogs pigs dream pigs there was a whole
anti-trump thing yeah you know did you
see him get caught lip syncing two weeks
ago no you see that was your video who
got caught up thinking uh roger waters
yeah there was video i posted it up
yeah uh look that up lee uh roger waters
uh lip syncing
2017.
yeah with these concerts you know do
they just want that name you know i
guess a lot of bands i think bon jovi
didn't bon jovi get caught doing that
yeah
a lot of these dudes are older and the
you know their voices are getting down
and they still got to make it
lip-syncing
is it the ozzy osbourne ghost singer
story nope it's just tapes so they have
tape in the back are they singing or are
they just moving their lips singing some
of them yeah are singing but yeah either
sometimes it's like
you could hear the top 60s yeah yeah
right we're very lucky to even have
these guys still have the you know i
just saw one of the funny i think
i love stand-up comedy yeah i love
people who are funny i think the
funniest person on this planet
on every [ __ ] interview i've ever
heard to me
funniest person on this planet is a man
my name is freely oh yeah right nobody
makes me laugh
harder yeah so what did you do when gene
was there i wanted the plans
while he played the bet you know it's
just he's he never stops yeah and he's
sober i can't imagine him
when he was you know somebody told me
he's 65 yeah yeah yeah is that what you
guys are telling me he's 65. he's up
there and he still shreds like the still
[ __ ] shredder he kills it did you go
to the sabon theater no but i zoo
did you go no no i saw him the year
before though man unbelievable he's
still shreds great kills years ago
somebody slipped me ace freely in the
comments oh yeah freely's comments not
the best albums in the world right but
the reason why i listened to him
constantly i was lifting weights it's
94.
94 i lived in boulder 93 94. and that
was my top cd because he shreds yep he
[ __ ] shreds he's he's uninhabited he
shreds he's um you know kiss was never
on my top uh five band list right but
he's in my top five guitar oh he's
underrated i don't know why something
about his style is always i'm not a big
kiss guy but i get props from pr you
know i don't like [ __ ] rush but
you're not gonna [ __ ] with neil perda no
i'm saying you're not gonna [ __ ] with
neil pert you're not gonna do it do you
like that uh solo album that ace did you
know when kiss did they're so loud
on it new york moves on that that's a
good one yeah yeah yeah i don't remember
2 000 man all that stuff he did was
great shockingly great bro i don't know
why you know lately i've been listening
to eddie trunk i love any trunk yeah i
love jimmy florentine and when it comes
to music and all that stuff i listen to
jim noise not into all those
[ __ ] oh yeah and the big news
is how kiss
like did two songs ace freely and jean
wrote two songs for ac yeah last week
new album crazy in a half an hour yeah
we never wrote two songs and a half an
hour why don't we took us in a couple
years yeah i mean he was hilarious honey
trunk an interview from june 30th i was
writing listening to it howling funny
any podcast i've heard in years yeah and
then you start
looking at his other things and you howl
the one with the makeup on and he's
talking about he invented the space man
oh that's coco's dripping from his
[ __ ] nose you can't write that [ __ ]
people don't even know that world where
people used to give interviews all
[ __ ] up oh yeah the early one where
they're on the couch and he's all space
bear remember that he's all drunk and
jeans pissed off it's tom uh
brokaw or what what's a tom um i forget
it's a late night one look up j uh ace
is drunk it's holy oh no i saw that one
oh my god he's like i got a space bearer
here and gene's like
jesus is losing his mind
during an interview old oh he was the
host oh it's like uh what's his oh my
god what's his name used to imitate him
on saturday night live um oh my god
blues brothers guy it's [ __ ] great
dan aykroyd would do him on uh
tom snyder tom snyder there it is you
gotta see this man it is hilarious he's
like i got a space ace bear gene simmons
are you serious
it was uh halloween of seven yeah yeah
watch how drunk he is it's awesome
you gotta kiss guy mauricio
um
not really i'm a kiss guy
you know i like their hits and stuff
like that like i said i started off a
kiss guy yeah but the guy who turned me
on to kiss died oh [ __ ] so at his
funeral i put all the kiss albums i had
in this casket kiss alive
rock and roll else i think i had three
albums at the time
and i said i'll listen to kiss when i
meet him in heaven and that was my only
kiss i just style listen to kiss bro
now i listen to them from time to time
at the house and i'm alone yeah and i
still like i found this song a couple
weeks i got choked up
i think about that kid all the [ __ ]
time anthony balzano so i get i got
choked up so that's why i don't listen
to kiss but
recently i've been getting involved in
all this [ __ ] again because it was big
when i was between the age of 11 and 13
kiss is huge in my world and led
zeppelin just
overpowered them you know once you
listen to sabbath bloody sabbath there
ain't going back to kiss there ain't no
going back you like the guy in the crowd
yeah yeah yeah yeah you're like yeah
there ain't no going back yeah hiddenly
hit it it's just [ __ ] curious
first of all mister uh jeans i saw this
tour
which is a dynasty tour 79. mr peter
the drummer mr paul stanley who was the
guitarist and ace freely who was the
lead guitarist i'm not
i'm the trout player
a trout player now tell how this started
you know because gene came in and he
said i didn't know i played bass and i
said well i see aykroyd on saturday
night live with the with the bass fish
and then you say the trout player that's
excuses face face
what would happen if you went out on
stage for a concert and you didn't set
off the fireworks and you didn't break
up the guitar and you didn't have the
smoke and the fire and the blood and all
that you just came out and did your
thing what would it would they come to
the silvia it would still be a
rip-roaring rock-and-roll show because
what we do when we go out there is we
don't stand still when we play our
instruments we run around and pretty
much raise hell can we say that on tv
yes you can well as hell tv
nice little track you know track and i'm
sure we're very we're very athletic
young gentleman i think
this is
i mean this isn't
you know going out like this so if we
didn't go out like there's a lot of
people would be really disappointed
because kiss is known for the big show
so
why shouldn't we go out and do what
people expect how does what you do now
in concert what we saw in the videotape
and i'm assuming that that's reasonably
recent how does it differ from when kiss
first went out on stage did you come out
with this tremendous energy right from
from day number the energy was there the
equipment wasn't we used to go out and
we wanted everybody to think we were
famous and that we have been to the
middle of it
when he brings out this stuffed bear in
the forest
just gets fierce you'll see it
all right
get into there yeah
let's see what we got here
he breaks out some [ __ ] stuffed bear
in its own
see the audience going crazy what goes
through your minds do you have time to
think about audience reaction while
you're performing i feel like i'm in a
movie i always get the feeling that that
you know without comparing ourselves to
anybody else it's almost like the
mid-60s like we're in a beetle kind of
movie and we're not even playing
ourselves because i mean when you
realize that a lot of the people at the
show have been waiting this is one of
the reasons why i don't like them to
come see us and this is too pompous
when you see all these people screaming
and crying and all that
he's crying why did i spend all that
money
[Applause]
i told you he's a [ __ ] nut
oh that's not that's nice man come on
that's nice
it's nice
you'll suffer
yeah we've been to gene and i were
together for about nine years now not
sexually just
that's the later part of the program
about nine years and then we broke up a
band we were in and peter joined us and
then ace joined us and uh the rest is
history we always wanted because i
always wanted christmas it's like
everything is
kissed the thing was we always wanted
the actress and music
uh can i just go around the horn here
and start with gene
let's see if you can see the bear in the
in the preview like where you can see
the
i don't know why pause do you remember
that there was a homeless guy who
pretended to be peter remember that he's
soon have you ever seen that no okay
here we go there we go get into it
there's where he's drank and [ __ ] here
we go that's good
and then and after it's all over they
say this is like
that
i stole this from flash gordon and uh
you know i have my cape man but you're
kind of like a space man huh
no actually i'm a plumber
[Laughter]
i got a little piece of pipe backstage
i'd like to have you work
on it
you need to work on i told you he's a
[ __ ] riot
he don't stop now he don't stop
i'll tell you i read on the sheet that
they gave me where they said that it's
hard to get you out of your shell
try to cheer down
that you wanted to go for a ride in the
first spaceship or a rocket ship or
something like that
are you referring to the space shuttle
the space shuttle
i would prefer to have a ride on the
first space shuttle if that's feasibly
possible i was speaking to pat
and i said you got any info any uh
secret answer see if you can get me a
ticket on that i'd be very interested in
that because i'm into a technology i
think ace doesn't need anything i think
he could just empower himself
[Applause]
his own power are they all jewish
yeah yeah that's just like they're all
nerdy jews
[Laughter]
in time right tom i'm having an awful
time
take you know take it easy it'll get
better
i
will hope so we will uh we'll
try this [ __ ] classic
that's a classic interview he cracks me
up yeah oh there's the bear right there
look
right there in the left corner there
there there it is yeah that one look
he's got the bear
no no you you missed it go back don't
worry about don't worry about the
[ __ ] man yeah yeah it was hilarious
hey where already got the hysterics um
he's [ __ ] yeah hilarious he's
hilarious and they were like i got
turned on to his thing like five years
ago i was into youtube and i haven't
stopped listening to everything he's got
yeah any interview because i know i'm
gonna laugh my [ __ ] at some point of
the interview you know
pretty [ __ ] rare gift to have and be
able to shred that hard and [ __ ] be
that funny i think he's gonna be back in
did they do drugs and get in like
partying and stuff because they know
they seem so nervous boys they [ __ ]
did
are you kidding me lee
yeah they were there man yeah you gotta
read aces first book it's unbelievable
man he said at one point oh no his
girlfriend wrote a book and she said at
one point he was staying over here in uh
you know studio city in 96 and i guess
he was tweaking on coke and he thought
somebody put like uh microphones in the
wall so he tore the sheet rock down
of all the walls in the house
and so when the when the landlord came
over he's like what the [ __ ] it was just
two by fours because he's like i know
you guys are spying on me oh
his girlfriend wrote this book it's
insane i heard he had
i had a i had a friend
that used to talk to him yeah every day
in boulder
they met 15 years ago
through drugs
and they were tight and he used to she
showed me a picture he had a lincoln
continental no one of those old
cadillacs yeah only [ __ ]
he would do something like this and when
you opened up his glove compartment it
was a sliding mirror oh
a mirror popped out like a was a thing
on an airline that you put down only it
was a mirror
so you could smoke who has that
he wasn't worried about getting pulled
over yeah i guess not
i just [ __ ] not can i have your
license
yeah like [ __ ] like that like
that's a different level like of of yeah
you know i
one of my
vivid memories way before how old are
you 27
way before you were born
one of the things that destroyed america
i still remember the newspaper articles
and the radio
was when guns and roses won
their grammys yeah they couldn't walk
yeah
look they couldn't walk mauricio
[ __ ] lit america was not ready for
that on a [ __ ] on tv on tv in 88 with
the war on drugs and everything and
these guys went up there
just tanked like they couldn't talk
that's by the way by the way yeah where
i live for guys yeah
i talked to the neighbor all the time
good guy he gave me a kitchen for my
daughter it's old
70-something the more more we talk the
more and more the guy's interesting he
did six years on fear factor wow
he did he did a movie that is
i forget what movie he did when he told
me oh smoking the bandit wow
like that's how old that guy is he was
like one of the camera guys
the one why i talked to this [ __ ] guy
tomorrow morning like this guy
his wife
ah
she wouldn't really talk to me i don't
blame her
i'm a [ __ ] scary guy
she's a good looking hippie chick i saw
her when i was over there good luck yeah
she's not trimming the car yeah good
looking woman man yeah little circular
glasses you could tell she smoked a
joint somewhere in her life but we just
never really connected well last night i
walk outside with mercy and she she
calls me over and she goes i want to
talk to you about something because i
saw your daughter walk in the end that
do you mind if i uh take pictures of
your daughter i'm like oh no she's for a
magazine
i'll get a couple grand you know me doug
yeah put it in the bank i don't give a
[ __ ] oh yeah because i'll let you know
it's a company that models dresses
and we could do it right in your
backyard with your wife
i said all right no problem
and uh i don't know we just started
talking i didn't know you were a
photographer
one thing led to the other you ready for
she goes you don't know you know my
ex-husband because then she started
telling me that
every day a couple days a week when i
pull out there's a kid mowing the lawn i
saw him there i saw him there he'll
better remember and he said hey joey
yeah so he told them he goes you live
next to [ __ ] this lunatic yeah
and
yeah so she went inside listen to a
podcast she goes oh my god
she goes by the way
i have to tell you something
and i thought it was going to be like
insulting as soon as she goes i listen
to your podcast
you were talking something about hearing
chinese music when we did cocaine i
[ __ ] lost it
and i looked at her and she goes yeah
she goes you know who my husband is i go
i don't know my ex-husband i don't know
jimmy axelrod he was a photographer
for
everybody wow really and they opened up
the [ __ ] uh the rainbow
oh wow yeah so she dropped the name on
me and i was like it sounds familiar she
goes oh yeah
she goes i'm [ __ ] slash's godmother
she went in the house baby pictures the
whole
pictures of them two years ago
oh my god you guys don't even talk for
years no no and then she [ __ ] took
pictures and she goes look at this house
take a good look at this i looked there
she goes bam
and it was a picture of her and neil
young in the same front with the husband
and the kids for hey hey my mind he
photographed the whole tour remember he
did a concert film yeah yeah yeah he did
the whole thing she's like yeah my
husband's like [ __ ]
gold with these people wow she still
married him no he died oh he died and
then she goes yeah he just didn't want
to stop living that life she goes i hope
you stopped i got 10 years ago oh yeah
yeah she's going to put you in a hole
yeah she goes this is a certain age you
can't be snorting coke and drinking
beers it's not going to work out for you
because it's just not she goes not
everybody had the jeans that lemmy had
yep she goes lemmy once a once in a
lifetime guy nobody could do that [ __ ]
bionic man yeah no no i i spoke to becky
by the way today
and she was telling me that she went to
a fourth of july party and i was talking
about drinking you know she said that
she had a few beers
and she goes i went home like nothing
but she goes i can't believe how much
the 3b has affected me oh yeah this
morning like my workout was bad i was
sluggish
i didn't sleep right i was thirsty all
night i go [ __ ] alcohol is weird when
you don't do it a lot oh yeah well it's
all sugar and then it's alcohol too so
you got the combo just destroying you i
had to stop yeah like i had to stop like
in 99 i was you know detained that
[ __ ] cocaine you you know i could
drink bro people think they see me all
more mold up that i drink so i [ __ ]
uh
my tolerance for alcohol
is the same as my tolerance for reefer
wow because i see like 80 stars i could
drink two beers and be a little buzzed
but
when i'm rocking and rolling i could
really go yeah the drugs would make me
really go but the hangover guys i
couldn't take and the older i got the
hangover got worse and worse i mean
hours head pounding
pukes body shaking convulsions i had to
stop drinking yeah that should [ __ ]
run you down you ever see people when
you go how old are you then they go 37
you're like whoa like they've been booze
in their whole life they look like
they're 60. hey look i used to be a
handsome [ __ ] until that cocaine
got a hold of me too
that cocaine runs that mileage up a
little too yeah cocaine's like that
thing when you change your miles
accelerator yeah yeah yeah yeah
cocaine's the accelerator yeah you were
mentally 89 but you [ __ ] around with
that powder for 30 years you do any
powder no i don't but i i know a really
good story about a cocaine there once
black sabbath i think they were in a
restaurant and then frank zappa was
there with his band yeah so if you know
anything about frank zappa he doesn't
let his uh his band members do any drugs
or anything like that he's really
against that in the band so this night
black sabbath and zappo were in the same
you know area and zappa's uh band
members were going up to sabbath and
asking for coke it's like hey you know
frank doesn't let us do any coke do you
have any coke can we do something so no
we don't have any sorry you know and
then another guy comes in he's like hey
do you guys have any cobra look at
nobody sorry and then frank zappa goes
up to black sabbath hey uh my uh my guys
are like his first coke would you have
any he's like no we don't so even frank
zappa knew that black sabbath was so in
a coke you know this was like volume
four era yeah um you know if you heard
stories they would have cereal boxes
filled with coke i think they were in
beverly hills they had like a pool it
was basically success after master
reality vol 4 just party all day and
then just record all night and but yeah
those guys were doing coke oh yes every
time snow blind
there's video then playing it and
there's like snow coming down and do you
have any idea like what
that era of music did to a guy like me
like i could either bought into
scientology
or
became somebody's sex slay when my
mother died i could have became a lot of
things and when you're that weak people
could talk you into a lot of things
to this day
i'm happy that the the
the void
the what
filled my whole
the first album which was the wall
yeah my mom died on the eighth the wall
tickets
went on sale like the 20th of november
well the concert was february 1st and
the album was getting released right
before christmas
people were waiting for the wall
mauricio
do you understand me like people were
[ __ ] waiting for the weather these
[ __ ] away from marvels
of the universe huh yeah
video games you have no idea the
anticipation of the wall and right there
like black sabbath was in limbo
so people were all confused nobody and
then when
rumors were he was making a comeback and
nobody knew what was really going on
because in those days there was no
internet mauricio there was circus and
cream magazine that's it rolling stone
didn't really fill you in on those they
didn't write anything no they didn't but
it's so weird like how
am i ashamed to say these things no
as you know my first sabbath down was
war pigs the second one was the first
one which i thought was a [ __ ]
masterpiece
and at that point was i doing cocaine or
not really when i bought the second
album i wasn't doing cocaine yeah that's
70 yeah seven yeah yeah but i didn't buy
it in 70. i bought it in 78. 79. he went
backwards here i went backwards i was
who introduced you to it was this a
friend just hey my high school is
my height my area of north bergen new
jersey at that time
ted was number one ted had just released
double live gonzo you couldn't stop that
that that's a matter of every party you
went to ted was on
no matter where you went in that part of
jersey ted was uh
i remember i had a i had a known school
i had a no-show job at horace mann
school
that some cop got me on something you
got to go in there the day you got paid
i don't know what that no-show job it
was
yeah and i'll never forget that one man
went looking for the supervisor and they
go he's up in the
in the third floor in the seventh grade
class and i walked in and you know
horace mann was in our school district
but not really we're low downtown
harvest man was uptown they had four
schools that represented us and then
i walked into the classroom and they had
like you know when you walk into a
classroom i have a b c d e f g around
the classroom oh yeah in the middle of
the classroom over the [ __ ]
blackboard
some kid had drawn a beautiful picture
of ted nugent pointing at you saying ted
says you must go ganzo wow i someone
drew that somebody drew that this is
summer of 80. yeah like that when ted
released wango tango people almost
jumped off a bridge yeah like my friends
were done like they were screaming
dreams
scream dream they were gonna kill
themselves
it was an end of an era aerosmith left
us hanging in 79 after not at the ruts
black sabbath broke up in 79 leonard
skinner went down with the [ __ ] plane
thought we were confused yeah so all of
us so i i was just went disco
and then i was made from disco yeah yeah
all right so now we're all confused
and i bought
war pigs the first one
and i went uptown one saturday afternoon
i'll never forget there's more racial
and this is the excitement that you give
me when i'm around you i'm gonna give it
back to you like there's nothing like
going to the record store
at that age the record store was bigger
for me than some chicks [ __ ] i could
tell you this right now guys absolutely
every saturday i pulled the gem out of
there it was either la woman i pulled
the beach boys out mouth that was crazy
you know as gay as it sounds but it's
not really the beach boys i pulled out a
bunch of albums every saturday in a row
a rainbow album that was brilliant i
forget what it was but one day in the
wall
right like in the glass somebody had put
sabotage up
mauricio when i saw sabotage my neck
care stood up and i went in i turned it
around
and i paid the 5.95 that was 4.99
whatever the [ __ ] it was
and you walked that out my home with
pride
and once you hit your neighbor and your
friends go what do you got and you
flipped me out [ __ ] sabotage oh [ __ ]
i'm coming over when is that party
tonight [ __ ] my mom's not gonna
be at home yeah and you walk in you put
the thrill of it all i almost jumped out
of the way no mauricio but i knew from
listening to that music
that cocaine was somewhere
then i bought master reality put it on
listen to two songs took it off
this is a little too heavy for uncle
joey we'll have to get black sabbath
you have to get black sabbath
it was a little bit too heavy for uncle
joey at the time it's like i've said
before on this no quarter when i first
bought it when i was like 12.
i would put on dancing days the other
one and jump over no quarters
no quarter was a little too deep at 12
for uncle joe scary without the reefer
yeah no coil is too deep with no
briefing though so there was music that
you listened to that did scare you like
that was at that time i didn't listen to
it it reminded me if it reminded me of
star trek music yeah i wouldn't listen
to it but i was a lot like you i was ray
my first love was black music
from four to six
that was my first love blues is jazz
[ __ ] everything
so temptation soul james brown that was
my first real introduction to music by
black people introduced me to it then my
second introduction was spanish music
which was [ __ ] brilliant for me i
love salsa i love
that conga [ __ ] from cuba that that afro
cuban [ __ ] i [ __ ] love it i would be
embarrassed to tell my friends i
listened to this
like in those days you didn't come in my
bedroom i wouldn't put that [ __ ] i would
put that [ __ ] on when i was by myself
you hide it four records back dirty hair
music which i referred to in those days
i was scared of that dirty hair music
dirty hair music my friends called the
dirty hair music what do you think about
when they mix that in and rock music
like in super naught that breakdown
there's all that pretty cool
the first time i love that but i just
had i was going to tell you guys the
first two albums i bought you ready yeah
first time i bought was yes fragile i
just had to have it
that was a great cover
and those songs are you know what is it
a roundabout oh yeah tremendous
and the second album i bought i almost
threw it away get your yayas out oh
i bought it by mistake oh you don't like
it huh i bought it by mistake i was i
wanted uh sympathy for the devil oh and
i saw that it was on there and i bought
it and i brought it home it was live i
was six years old live record furious i
was like this is [ __ ] you don't like
that one joey i at the time i didn't
play live music right oh wow i wasn't
prepared for that oh really live music
and then i bought like the restaurant
and all that stuff all that [ __ ] uh
crazy horse and
rust never sleeps yeah big album
you know what else is uh
then you know of course double life
gonzo's live and then if you want blood
is live all those live records were
really what made those bands take off
well you know buddha khan you know what
i mean that's the [ __ ] that people love
the cheap trick buddha con all the live
records were the huge ones you know the
the skinner one from the road isn't that
crazy
that stuff you know
i love it man the live i love it i i had
to learn to love it i'm not gonna lie to
you gotcha when i first heard live music
i was in shock because i thought i was
going to hear you play
to the t from the owl perfect okay
and then i listened to a few albums and
i hated all of them i'm like this is
[ __ ] garbage yeah yeah this is all
garbage and then somebody gave me an
eight track and it had
the allman brothers live oh yeah phil
moore east and that made me think about
something because i had never heard them
do the studio side right right so i fell
in love with the side version first but
then there was another album on that
eight track which was called the song
remains the same oh now i put that on
yeah
and i'm like what the [ __ ] is this
that's the [ __ ] dude this is powerful
and then i bought the albums backwards
oh yeah so i listened to the live led
zeppelin and i bought two
i bought one i bought uh presents which
at first i thought was a mistake and i
ended up falling in love with it right
you know we fall in love with albums
like cats sometimes we get a cat that's
not a good looking guy it's not my
princess but i didn't want the
[ __ ] to die he's missing a foot
yeah but within three years you don't
know the love in this [ __ ] is
gonna give you know this do you have
albums like that oh yeah i remember i
remember you two oktong baby okay i
bought it you know i love joshua tree i
got home i put it on i returned it you
couldn't return records back then but i
said no no man i don't like this at all
and then i saw them about three months
later on mushrooms and they played the
octon baby stuff i went oh [ __ ] i get it
i get it i get it now it was just way
over my head instantly and now one of
the top records i own of all time how
about you mauricio ever happened to you
like a like a band that you have to
listen to yeah they get yeah i got
exactly it's right here it's this band
they're from france
they're called magma
they're from 1973. i know this bad they
made up their own language
so all the lyrics are very like you know
you don't even know what what it is
because they use their voice as an
instrument so kind of chanting
really dark haunting like
uh carl orf meets you know just satan
satanic say chant it's not
it's not satanic music but just the
sound of it's very intense ways getting
scared scary it's the most it's the
scariest music i've listened to it took
me a while i first listened to what the
[ __ ] is this you know what what is this
noise you know you just don't know what
you know your mind isn't processed with
with all these sounds
it sounds very smart because they're
from france and they're like well the
biggest markets america
so no i mean they can do this everywhere
they didn't sell at all they didn't sell
at all you know they're underground they
didn't even try it's not pop music it's
not trying to they're just this guy
named christian bander who's the drummer
he composed all the music
and uh yeah this album
mechanic destructive commando is one of
the most intense
albums i've ever listened to and yeah it
takes it took me a while to get it
really wild it takes you a while it was
somehow by the temptation somebody gave
me once
first i listened to it and it it was too
slow for me i liked the faster moving
soul music and this was too slow for me
i listened to it years later and i got
it
i got what they were doing you know
sometimes you're just not prepared for
now i'll tell you where that happens a
lot too comedy oh yeah sometimes you
write a joke at your six year mark that
you laugh your ass off while you're
writing
and while you say it on stage one of
your comedian friends gets it and he's
howling yeah and then he'll tell you do
it for me dog get bombs
you know what i'm saying yeah yeah yeah
okay just do it for me come on dog i'll
buy you a hamburger and you're like okay
you do it and bombs but you and him both
how yeah and then you throw the joke
away
and years later it comes back to you
and you drop it now you're like kill him
with it yeah because you weren't
delivering it right or your confidence
level there's always something but
back to music it's so weird how i've had
i think volume four i bought volume four
for snow blind
look what it says right there and i
think that volume four was one of those
albums also that was a bit deep for me
right and then i fell in love with it
look who they think right there
thing yeah i love it like the great i
said oh my god i still remember these
show dean that picture looking
oh yeah this is when they got a gold
i know a lot of people listening to this
right now going like right now dean is
looking at the inside of an album cover
yeah you get the love that we got i just
love it because in those days this is
what you look at i saw my god i'm
getting goosebumps
look at geez you know how many times i
would roll the joint knees oh yeah the
joint and then go back shuffle out the
seeds remember shuffle out the seeds
this is great
hey look at this wall titles published
by roller joint music
where do they thank coke right here
special thanks special thanks
to the great coca-cola yeah no no guys
this [ __ ]
fuels i'll never forget you know how he
says uh lying at the end after you find
peace he goes lying snow blind in the
sun
i still remember
being 16 and we used to cut through the
cemetery hell me and dede cantero and a
bunch of us and one day me and dede
would come to the cemetery
it had to be one of those days where you
went brought a jacket to school but it
turned out to be hotter than what it was
and i bought like a half gram of coke
and we walked to the cemetery and i go
dog what would it what can you imagine
if we laid here and got sun and snow
that coke it'd be like snow blind
and we both laid into him did a couple
lines
laid in different tombs and got sun for
like 10 minutes like two [ __ ] we
walked out of there we thought with tony
naomi and i was the osmo walking out of
like two [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's how stupid i [ __ ] got on that
[ __ ] yeah look at this yeah this is the
album right here that's a rare mexican
edition the only one that's ever came
out in gatefold wow
is it in spanish
the titles are in spanish they're all
written in spanish
music's normal that's great
on the uh during the last concert in
birmingham toni umi played the thrill of
it all
he played it he was playing riffs
different riffs from from sabotage
different riffs from vol 4. when i went
to go see them at the hollywood bowl i
went to soundcheck and he played super
naught he played symptom of the universe
he played a sweet leaf so he came out
ozzy didn't come out so it was just him
the drummer and geezer so they were
playing and they were just i recorded it
i'll send it to you i'll put it up on
youtube that's great because you went to
that show right you went to the
hollywood bowl show i did i went
oh yeah it was monday september 25th i
started new york that week and i was
leaving on a wednesday yeah so i had to
do two podcasts i had to do monday and
tuesday i got off a plane that sunday
and that's the way and now i'll see him
again you know it's it's really weird
i have a friend that's uh in fact i saw
him last week in san francisco
and years ago he said something to me
we were giggling he goes you know what
you can never go back
you know sometimes you can never go back
on certain memories you know
and i think about my black sabbath
memory with van halen
it's a it couldn't have been a [ __ ]
better memory i mean i felt bad for
sabbath even at that point in my concert
life
i knew they sounded like [ __ ]
like something was this was terrible
yeah he sounded like that you know
there's some some people you were
aerosmith
first time i saw them oh my god it was
outside oh yeah they didn't really have
it down no they did because i've seen
leonard skinner from oakland they had it
outside for all those shows yep this was
the meadowlands in 77 and 76. that
meadowlands
and uh frank marino mahogany rush who
shredded the [ __ ] guitar smoking poco
and it was just i remember that concert
like it was just i was a kid walking the
giant stadium and walking home yeah we
left there while ted was still on stage
before the first encore and we were on
route 3 and you could still hear [ __ ]
ted from route 3. you know what that's
like as a kid you're like jesus christ
ted was insane back then people don't
understand like ted is uh you know
people are like oh he's like this right
wing lunatic and stuff nah nah that
happened 15 20 years ago right but back
in the 70s 70 000
seats sold out like these football
stands i saw them at oakland where they
a's play and you saw them a giant and
and people going
ballistic i mean crazy the entire time
he's on
like one guy up there just killing it on
guitar and a whole arena i'm not arena a
baseball field now
jackson holmes that was his name his
name was um uh uh
scott
marx you know or something yeah saint
holmes but when that guy left after
weekend warriors yeah that was his last
album i need you bad is that still him
singing yeah that's him and then ted
it's like him and ted would uh go back
and forth correct right right right
right i remember going to see them
august 4th 1979
at uh
the garden and it was ted and
ac dc was opening up at that yes right
for highway to hell you knew
you just knew
yeah like at that time you just knew at
that time i had been i was starting to
get burned
the rule was you never went to see the
warm-up man if you wanted to be cool
nobody goes to see the warm-up man
but now we were starting to get burned
because warmer bands were starting to
get really good they were doubling up on
them so maurice are you ready for this
think about being 15 16 jazzed up on
this [ __ ]
and it was iron maiden killers
yeah with judas priest
you know uh the one after breaking the
law
oh yeah
no been for leather no no after breaking
british steel oh no british steel is
yeah breaking the law right hell bent
for leather is the one before bro
screaming for vengeance
with the eagle with the eagle maybe and
the other one the
other ones defenders of the face no no
way before the defenders in the face so
this is
this is in between i mean are you
[ __ ] kidding me i made them with paul
diana at the theater the palladium which
was a theater in new york city yeah
and then i got i didn't get burned i got
burned on nazareth oh nazareth came and
whoever the opener was
lit the [ __ ] place on fire like
nazareth had to take like a xanax and
calm down and [ __ ] whoever opened up for
them at the palladium also who was june
6th until this day i forget wow there
was somebody who just was rapping in
those days yeah we
could find it it wasn't like billy
squire or something like that with
somebody [ __ ] just like lightning
and then i went to see uh
again judas priest showed up another
year with def leppard
for
not breaking the law again but it was
around that it was
between breaking the law
you know when they come the second time
yeah that's when they showed up with
duff leopard for
uh right before i was on through the
night but they were doing songs from uh
hi high and dry my head almost blew up
and again that's another sleeper again
that was uh that was the first appetite
for destruction oh yeah because that got
released in december but it didn't start
[ __ ] lighting people on fire till
june
crazy how music travels you know when's
that 30 years it's coming up in two
weeks
is july 21st
how did you uh discover bands that word
of mouth or do you like you just said
you would just go to concerts and just
see the openers i had a very music
neighborhood i was very fortunate and
every neighborhood different offered
different things
like i still remember my freshman year
being in study hall
and my friend who i ended up moving in
with a year later steve ronnie looks at
me and he gives me
unleashed in the east
i look at these [ __ ] people like are
you [ __ ] crazy
at that time i'm black sabbath loyal
zeppelin loyal
you know like i don't know anything
about this [ __ ] you're throwing at me
judas priest oh my god i took that
[ __ ] eight track home whatever the
[ __ ] it was
i played it you know by the time i got
the
diamonds and rust yeah i was like wait a
second there's something here
and then victim of changes in the center
if i could have done heroin i woulda i
was 15. i couldn't find you know that's
how good it was
and after that
my mother died
and
i had moved them with the benders
i had something
they were playing at the palladium on
the hell bent for leather tour
and i [ __ ] went over there with a
bunch of dudes lost them in those days
you get single seats for like 10 bucks
and i went to see them know on a whim
like on a whim when he came out with
that [ __ ] motorcycle come on guys
yeah yeah nobody was doing that no and
then those days he come off the bike
with a whip yeah yeah
those two [ __ ] guys would come out
and start [ __ ] playing
one on one side one on the other and you
go what the [ __ ] is going on in front of
my eyes man it was just beautiful you
know and uh
just all that [ __ ] i i loved it i i took
chances yeah after a while i started
taking chances
without yelp you know what i'm saying i
took chances yeah because i heard things
yeah that's like i heard things lee and
i took chances yeah so i went to see
james brown i went to see bands that i
normally wouldn't go see like i really
yes was a band i went to see five years
in a row and every year they got worse
and worse
you know i'm saying from like
77 to yeah
tremendous yeah uh
i still miss that
mauricio you would die okay so you see
us full
we grew up together and we're music
nerds and we smoke dope together and you
know what one of these days we're gonna
get the balls
and we're gonna try acid
oh [ __ ]
did you just hear what wplj said did you
just hear that
[ __ ] the who's going on sale tomorrow
so in those days it was completely
different mauricio you knew this right
mm-hmm yeah they would give you an
address
and you'd have to mail the money order
your mom would have to write a check for
us for you got to pay for four tickets
in advance yeah yeah so us four would
cut a deal here's the deal you're gonna
buy four you're gonna buy four you're
gonna buy four and i'm gonna buy four
they would play four nights
you follow zanty so i would go for
monday you go for tuesday and [ __ ]
100 percent we go three out of four yeah
we go over anyway out of respect let's
go over there let's see if we can crack
a lack of [ __ ] that's how it was you had
you know judas priest came to new york
monday through friday at mauricio we're
at the stadium in new york city
before they really wanted to take
chances with
the garden and arenas
do you know what that's like when you're
a kid
monday through friday a bus ride away
into the capital of the [ __ ] world to
go see judas priest
at a [ __ ] theater can you please
check that for me july
of 1980 judas priest hellbent uh british
steel tour i wonder who opened for them
oh yeah we could find that they're going
to be playing at the whiskey who judas
priest jesus christ now with but the
thing is it's a rock and roll fantasy
but it has rob halford the bassist and
the guitar player yeah so
you know yeah these guys
tipton no no it's the new guy
so who left
the blonde yeah
he just retired yeah he didn't like it
anymore yeah you know what he did he he
opened a golf course man in like england
or something you know he he was just
he's like you know we've done it like a
million years and they said they were
gonna you know retire
i went to that retirement show and then
when they got done they're like no we we
still want to keep playing and kk was
like i'm retiring like we said
now they got this guy richie faulconer
and he [ __ ] smokes
i mean smoking looks like kk 10 feet
away plays like kk the same thing the
flying v
up in the air you know on the center all
that well it's become kind of like
rock star like rock
we're
star
yeah
band and i got two of us
i'm just going to start go to 10
different cities and look for the
[ __ ] judas priest cover bands youtube
yeah and you too yeah boston with the
guy from home depot
a guy you know was his daughter the guy
from striper who was singing for boston
there's two of them two guys yeah but
the guy from striper but this other guy
they got from home depot
and [ __ ] i went and saw him dude and
uh the guy put up some songs of him sing
in boston it's his favorite song his
daughter uploaded him on to youtube
and uh then boston said
is this is this you really singing he
said yeah
and he sounded just like brad delp and
they brought him down and he's been in
the band like 13 years now or something
who's touring right now what's the band
with like an asian guy
oh that's uh
yeah i want to say that lee so it's 1980
right right yeah so you probably went to
new york yes july 12th july 12th through
what
um
it just says the palladium july 12th all
right who was the opening band uh
i i don't think it says on this
damn let's see if i can find it yeah but
yeah like you said i've been all the
concerts i've seen uh some of the bands
that go on is just one member of an
older band and the rest of the group is
just younger cats foreigner there's just
one original guy yeah one dude's
original guy and he and he
last year was sick and didn't even go
out so there's no original guys in the
band none they're out there i wanna know
what love is you know there's no guy in
the band there's two yes bands one of
them doesn't have any original members
yeah it has steve howe but he's not an
original member then the other one has
john anderson rick wakeman and trevor
revin yeah from the 80s that's that's
who i want to go see i rather prefer to
see john anderson sing than some you
know younger guy or whatever but yeah a
lot of bands now they're just you know
roger waters it's just roger waters and
the rest of the band's just new people
you guys were having a great
conversation before we started the
podcast
i
i grew up in a shed all right let me
rephrase this
my friend stephen avillo who i still
speak to
had a shed behind this house no heat
but in the dead of the winter he had
marshall lamps because he played the
guitar he's still in the band today like
they just do cover soon
but he's recovering he had open heart
surgery my heart goes out to emma's
family he walks every day he was making
spaghetti sauce last week he's back
when we were kids that was our sanctuary
and he we listened to with his brother's
albums there was a lot of kinks
yeah there was a lot you know kings have
a couple of songs there's a lot of shot
i didn't like that i didn't believe in
but they were big stones
they were huge sabbath
and they were ginormous pink floyd
that's why i got my pink
first time i ever heard animals i heard
in that backyard
and i went and got it the next day and
then no
but i had
dark side of the moon right from the
store yeah like that was one of my first
albums also that i liked from the
beginning i really liked and one of my
first first acid trips i took acid by
mistake like i did
i'm standing like not my mistake like i
both i wasn't full uh what's that called
i wasn't fully cockley okay like i holy
[ __ ] yeah i got the i got this i took
the ass on a sunday
and i wasn't sure and blah blah blah and
i [ __ ] went home and i still remember
this guys i had the 8-track player that
you put the 8-track player here like
this the 8-track here yeah the speaker
was here
and i laid down and i drank like four or
five heinekens which was way above my
normal
alcoholic beverages in those days i was
like maybe 13 yeah 14 and a half maybe
yeah and i took uh
it was the first time it was the
first time i took a little piece as it
the second time was at the stones
foreign wow i put this little
piece of paper in my tongue yep and
nothing happened for a while
nothing happened until i went home
it took a long time to kick in like i
went no oh somewhere i had to go in
focus
i went home i put pink floyd on
and i was a little tired from the beers
and i laid my head back
and that's
when it started [ __ ] tripping the
first time and all i could hear is not
it was that creepy song from that no
singing it just takes you to a tunnel
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah on the run on the
run i said on the run yeah i was going
to say that on i have an album on uh
on the wall that's called something like
that on something so i didn't want to
get him confused yeah he was on the run
that was my first
real acid with taking your first
psychological ride and solo the walls
were going like this
my ears were ringing i could hear the
music it was pretty interesting yeah i
sweated out and the next thing i woke up
and i had a piece of gum on my shoulder
i puked that night i was asleep
and i didn't tell nobody and i was
prepared me for the two-month plane when
i was supposed to do some [ __ ] assets
oh man you went to acid training camp i
went to house a trading camp that's
great i remember
i hit i took solo just on a sunday
afternoon it was a mickey mouse on it
i was walking through the hate guy said
i said yeah [ __ ] i bought one
and i went home sunday afternoon took it
whoa man it was
way sometimes the way stronger you go
come on man when's this end
i had a black light or a neon a
budweiser neon in my [ __ ] bedroom
and i was glued on that for hours these
things would kill you maurice you ever
take acid and look at these things in
the middle of the night no the most
thing uh
just shrooms
i gotta hit acid here for you mauricio
i got some liquid ass i know we'd like
to do it here with you i'll do it with
you i could wait for a good concert i'm
good i'm good yeah uh you said something
interesting i'm all set that sativa hit
you bro that's great thank you i love it
yeah way better very nice great taste oh
it tastes great it didn't blow up my
lungs and it's perfect you know what it
is it's the stoned after i was on the um
the 24 carat when i came back in and was
rubbing that's where you are now
i said give me a sativa that won't take
you over the hill what was that one
called this one it's nice flower power
it's really good yeah clean man yeah you
know what i mean like i went in there
tonight and she gave me two free grams
i bought two weights so i go give me two
sativa i ubered over on purpose i was
like sure sure because you're a [ __ ]
professional and i'm wrong i'm rolling
no sleep it's great just all night in
new york and uh straight up to 5 a.m to
jfk caught that uh 6 30 virgin
you know like a doctor edited the
podcast all the way home was it packed
the flight oh yeah yeah yeah for fifth
of july oh a bunch of rookies out
rookies were out today
i had a guy in front of me
uh he he he you know the tsa scans the
ticket he just walked away they're like
your ticket dude he's uh oh okay and
then he got to the x-ray i'm tsa
pre-check i don't know how the [ __ ] he
got in there hey he took his watch off
and he didn't even put it on the
conveyor belt part he just walked
through and you know he didn't put it
through
it's just sitting on the thing anybody
could have just grabbed his watches oh
rook is wrapped you don't touch nothing
i don't touch nothing they got more
cameras oh yeah oh yeah i don't touch
nothing i one day i saw money cash oh
yeah and my initial was started like oh
you know what no i'm not putting myself
to this drama because there may be 800
there by the time i get to the police
and give it to him somebody's like come
and ask and all they got to do is let's
look at the videotape yeah and they see
chubby joey picking it up and they're
going to go white you i'm going to
donate it to some home uh white [ __ ]
pick it up yeah [ __ ] it yeah who pays
you mauricio
uh i just work uh i do freelance on my
own so they buy all those pictures that
you some people buy them and some you
know in most publications they just you
know they just say hey well you're going
to the shows for free you know
you know they don't pay me most of them
you know i just i'm just building up my
portfolio but i have a day job so
basically what do you do
uh
merch oh you do merch oh yeah first of
all he has some amazing rock pins here
that the detail is incredible he made me
this appetite for destruction one and
then my favorites are cheech and chong
and he brought those and then of course
metallica was known as alcoholica they
had their own merch privately that they
would wear these shirts and uh because
they pride their self on drinking as
much jaeger as they could
and so they were alcoholic and mauricio
made the logo i love this man
who do you do merch for bands uh bands
or just you know different designs for
myself stuff like that
this is uh
robbie krieger and john densmore wow
they played for celebration of uh
uh rayman zurich uh-huh he passed away
they're doing that thing at the fonda
you ever seen this where they have like
they say this is jim morrison on a cross
oh wow
it looks like him
looks like him that la woman record
right there son is a masterpiece you
know how he died there's a a folk singer
back in the 60s named marianne faithful
yeah and then she was she used to date
like uh mick jagger and she was arrested
with the rolling stones they they
thought they were doing some crazy stuff
and then
she ended up having a boyfriend who was
a drug dealer and because she was you
know around all these rock stars he had
easy access to sell this stuff so he
sold jim morrison and i think he sold
also
janice joplin's heroine the heroine that
killed him
so marianne faithful's boyfriend was the
one who like gave him the the heron was
too pure i think that's what i heard he
actually died in like a
like a disco hall or something you know
like a club and then i guess some people
like moved them to the uh oh yeah well
that's the old store that moved into the
bathtub yeah it recently came up because
it wasn't like his anniversary yeah
and it came up i was reading through and
then they buried him right away before
the band was even there so it's all all
those conspiracies is he really in there
did he really die
and then they wanted him kicked out of
that shay you know the uh i went there
joe you ever been there you go to jim
morrison's grave yeah i was there last
week
right yeah yeah yeah yeah last week last
week right people were shooting
it was [ __ ] you know tel aviv it was
tremendous
i went there though i had i had to go
i went and the head was still there
someone stole the head
at the grave what a bunch of dicks i
went to bruce lee's grave oh yeah some
shout out to you oh yeah where's that at
bruce lee's crab seattle oh sick you go
to hendricks crave too
no hendricks and him are separated
because somebody tried to it was too
much traffic oh wow somebody trying to
break into [ __ ] hendricks's grave or
something like that number one i want to
thank my main agent
gordon warnock for sending me two great
books
he listens to the podcast and he knows i
love him with all my heart
that's why we're gonna have a proposal
for him for the by the end of august so
he can get this ball rolling also my
main man
geno castro you bad [ __ ] i love
you at all my heart
thank you for the albums he gave us the
black sabbath album and uh
and uh the cuban album
and he also sent some great shirts he
put savage on him and he knows we love
him thank you very much thank you
brother and uh also tyler alvarez
sal paradise james harrison uki uki sexy
spooky alexander gonzalez aaron wade
jonathan hernandez bobby sharon and my
girl crystal down there and i want to
give a shout out to that podcast the
cobra cash
podcast [ __ ] tremendous
bobby's a bad [ __ ] she's a
tremendous uh chef of the future
and that's the way it is how you feeling
lee tremendous don't forget myself and
my main man dean delray will be at the
south point casino friday night and
saturday 7 30 show you're out of there
by nine o'clock
okay number two next week st louis
helium oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] you better get
nelly on the phone then the week after
that philly don't [ __ ] around
last time i went to helium it was packed
i know that this is jersey coming in you
don't [ __ ] around the borgata july 29th
go to borgata.com take it to 25 bucks
that's it ping ping boom you're done you
follow me
maurice you're a very interesting guy
i've known you for a while you always
show up at the store
there's always a black see you
you really knew my love of black sabbath
and you kind of rekindled it like i've
always loved them they have always been
my favorite band
but you kind of rekindled them like i
got into reading again about them and
just you know sometimes you get home
at night from a comedy club man and
that's my best time to listen to music
there's no more tv in my house when i
get home from the comedy club now
i get [ __ ] stoned as [ __ ]
and i come down with music
and i read about the old [ __ ] i used to
like to read about or something i'm
interested in reading about you know
but it was i can't tell you how many
times i put snow blind on
and did 10 [ __ ] lines of coke out of
respect i can't
even [ __ ] tell you like how much they
really pulled me in
and once i heard sweet leaf jesus
[ __ ] crap
and then there were always rumors
he was always the last two albums he was
always boogie
but then they finally took a picture
circus
circus took a picture of him like in 78
and it was the stem but he had a
blizzard of eyes shirt already
so there were already rumors that he was
leaving
when that blizzard about once i saw a
blizzard of ours i started snorting even
more
okay way before the [ __ ] first album
came out with rudy zarzo and yeah the
other guy i was by that time i was on a
[ __ ] mission from hell and how i
discovered that album was i came into a
little [ __ ] doe i went into the city
i went to blee kebabs legendary music
place hell yeah and when i was in there
i saw the ep
with blizzard of odds four songs
whatever the [ __ ] it was my my mind
exploded
because the last time this was
i can't even tell you when this was but
the last time i had read anything about
black sabbath ozzy was kaput he was done
m.i.a
nobody was going to see him black
sabbath was already back in the studio
and they reported with he and gilman but
by that time yeah that's how slow news
traveled in those days
that's why when everybody said dio who
the [ __ ] whoa whoa whoa whoa what
happened to him gillen giesel
done gone it's [ __ ] ronnie james d
who the [ __ ] was bonnie james deal so
everybody went out and bought stargazer
oh yeah that's everybody everybody
started listening to stargate i don't
know this guy's not going to pull off
cyber and just the conversation you guys
are having about pink floyd that
happened with sabbath
there was a wall it was like trump and
hillary yeah people lost their minds
[ __ ] you man if you go see [ __ ]
sabbath with deal you would never a
purist [ __ ] you man
you don't know how many people looked at
that album happening in hell and said
the sound was gonna blow
that's an album that you brought home if
you really loved ozzy osbourne you put
it on and you
sat there
and by [ __ ] that fourth song you're
like
i really want to hate this [ __ ] yeah
yeah i can't yeah like having the hell
they got three or four jams oh and tony
naomi you turned me into that born again
yeah what's that got on there re
animator it's got hero the zero right no
no yeah and also the song born again and
then it's got uh things out there ian
gillan
yeah it's got the uh what's the priest
song um
something the priest um oh god that
record is great man
you know it just comes in
it comes on like so weird and spooky
it's pretty scary that record and then
like i switched governments
it was the weirdest thing
i i went to boulder and
i lost my music collection and i uh
got away from my roots
here you go oh thrashed that was the uh
video i won't get thrashed again
and then uh disturbing the priest that's
the one i was talking about [ __ ]
great and then digital [ __ ] stay away
from the digital [ __ ] the digital [ __ ]
the story with this album is the cover
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
digital [ __ ] that's a great song
you know the story of the cover
the guy worked for
ozzy
and and sabbath said we want you to do
our cover and he's like he didn't want
to betray ozzy so he said i'll draw the
ugliest cover and they'll turn it down
and they took it
he was [ __ ] bombing man ozzy's like
how do how do you draw their cover you
traitor and look at it man it's like uh
the saint satan baby like rosemary's
baby i think it's pretty cool-looking i
love it me too
so like after they broke up with with
dia with deal left
the management was like all right what
are we gonna do how do we get a new
vocalist so one of the ideas was to get
robert plant because around that time
you know uh the led zeppelin was
disbanded he's like what 80
what is that 82 or something 83 yeah is
that 83 more yeah by that time guys i
was gone out of music yeah
by 83 i was on a burglary scam
listening to
well yeah i didn't even like to cover
this like now they were you know what i
got into uh holy diver oh yeah like i
switch
camps i don't want to hear this [ __ ]
what are you doing i'm done joey i saw
that tour at the cow palace and it was
so bad uh ticket sales i'm telling you
that the scalpers came in
and so they couldn't sell the tickets so
they came in there's only 5 000 in a 13
000 seater and in the middle of the show
a guy stuck another guy and he went down
he was bleeding everywhere and it was so
scary because there was a guy just
gutted in the middle of the cow palace
this music's going this evening horrible
yeah and there's no one there
it was crazy i mean no no by that time i
was long gone it was holy dive yeah what
the [ __ ] was i listening
the only diver 83 some priest
yeah old priest
you know i switched governments with
madonna oh yeah rather than aspen at
that time i went right to madonna's
first album like a virgin era no the one
before that the first one tremendous did
you read a tupac's letter to madonna
what did it say i didn't read breaking
up with her he basically said i can't be
with you because you're white because
i'm such a black icon and you're a pop
you know white chick i can't be with you
so he just breaks up with her yeah it's
a full letter they said it's going to
get like 500 000
it's going to go up for sale but it's
like a real he said and i i want to
kindle up our friendship again i was a i
was an idiot and if you could come visit
me in prison it would be great like
another job taken away by
by the internet you can't sell
copies of emails now
copies
that's what i'm saying it's another job
taken away oh
lee you're killing you're killing the
people's future
i don't know yeah save your notes so you
could sell them later so start right now
a lot of post office we're gonna close
on saturdays like a lot of people gonna
start closing friday delivery
and then something must have happened we
got stamped sales out of somewhere
people got pissed off they threatened
they said you [ __ ] want to keep
emailing yeah okay keep them out yeah
guess what we're shutting down saturday
starting november 28th i'm gonna keep
emailing yeah you don't wanna keep
emailing we're shutting down sally's
birthday we're shaking down the emails
white people got [ __ ] nervous
what if i don't get by my periodicals
i'm struggling you know my white people
get dog they get all nervous about my
amazon my amazon you know and then they
threatened then they said we're really
gonna put the mafia pressure on them you
know what
one friday month we're just going to
close the post office out of respect
so you won't get those government checks
you weren't going to get those
government checks and we're going to
close on the 5th we're going to close
that first [ __ ] friday saturday
rent's gonna be late oh that's when
black people puerto ricans
everybody who gets a check on a friday
he said [ __ ] you
we're going back to the stamps doug
okay went right back the stamps and now
everything's [ __ ] beautiful we're
back to stamps
but the post office had to put a
shutdown on [ __ ] oh man yeah
yeah that they were they were closed
every other saturday or whatever yeah
i'm done yet they threatened to start on
saturdays and then they said you know
what we're gonna do
we're gonna shut down the first friday
of the month people
that's it listen marco from now and
expect the letter you know saying
no more [ __ ] text
yeah because everybody's texting and
sending the emails that's yeah and you
can't break into your handwritten the
only people who send letters are
prisoners yeah that's it i used to write
letters like a [ __ ] when i was
in prison
and when people go to prison now i write
them letters yeah oh that's got to make
your day right you know it makes my day
and it makes dead day i got a guy now
that's [ __ ] well he gave us the tv
and he did a lot of good things for us
and he got locked up for the reasons
unknown that none of my business i know
what they are but i can't judge him i
would have done the same thing
yeah close to a million it's not like
he's robbing pogba books
he tried to work somebody over seven
figures that's we're gonna do it go for
brook oh yeah white color correct you're
gonna go rob somebody for forty thousand
out of their safe at gunpoint yeah i'm
saying that's very generosic whoa you're
gonna love baby driver dude
i don't know if i'm gonna go see it
leave me the [ __ ] alone all right oh
zero chance of you going to see that
movie you never know [ __ ] yeah but
he can see it at home later i'm gonna
stay home and [ __ ] uh watch conveyor
belts bring my food i should it would be
amazing jerry you and i oh no
maybe you and i see it in vegas it's in
vegas yeah during the day tremendous
i'll see it again
what's your next concept my brother
um
i'll go see him with you you know
there's a couple of them that scorpions
are playing at the forum
what's the date i think it's in october
okay october
let's go to that
there's slayer playing
they're coming up you know the last time
i've seen the scorpions yeah blackjack
82
blackout with rainbow unbelievable joel
and turner the logos are playing dodger
stadium yeah
we're not going to that though
are you taking pictures
yeah oh my god wait would max on that
fleetwood mac doobie brother santa
and what's the date on that i think it's
next weekend
west is next weekend i believe so
i was just july city field they're doing
it there too joey
both coasts well west and east yep now
who's on the east bill same bill same
band they're just different you know
how do you know it was two days too and
they split the bands i thought they all
played on one day and it was two days
but yeah one day is like eagles and
and yeah you don't see all of the bands
both days if you really want to see the
eagles you go one day if you really want
to see steely dan you go the other day i
want to see fleet with mac now what year
were you born in 89 okay so let me ask
you a question here on the hub it up
one of the eagles one of my favorite
eagle songs is one of these nights
i think that song came out in 1975
killer
just a
just a killer [ __ ] track you know
almost 15 years before you were born
you know
what makes you like bands like these a
guy like you 28 that
most 28 year old guys are jumping up and
down taking ecstasy and stuff like that
what attracts you to this music
i think um i think my family you know
environment they grew up they're
christian from mexico so they got that
music in them they play music and then
me when i first listened to the beatles
i don't know it's just it's a it's like
a
it's a drug i don't know every new band
has a different sound every different
band you know especially back in the 70s
a lot of them used instruments so
they're just sounds that
that you just don't hear anymore back
then they would take the time to
you know mix an album an album was an
album it was a piece of work you would
have to sit down put on your headphones
you know put on a good speaker listen to
the whole thing the sequence sequence
now it's just
you know pop music you just go one in
here one ear go out the other you know
but back then all that music you said
pink floyd the wall there's a whole
movie
about it you know the magma stuff like
look at this this is a
jethro told thick as a brick and they
they took their time to to do a whole uh
there's newspapers paper yes sick
that's why they really gave a [ __ ]
you know they wonder why the music
business
is in the sugar look at that yeah
wouldn't you want to pay and how much
were these albums at the time 490
[ __ ] five if you joined columbia
house you got 13 of these [ __ ] for a
nickel and [ __ ] for a penny
look at this [ __ ] yeah this took longer
than the other day i'm looking at a
newspaper ladies and gentlemen right now
that fit in an album that was an album
was in it and they folded it up they
took the time you know what this meant
to you as a as a 13 year old 15 year old
adolescent
this was [ __ ] the next every time
they came to town you were gonna gonna
go see him you know lemmy's first band
hawkwind yeah i love him you've heard of
them love them this is uh love hawkwin
space ritual oh that's great when you
love him joey straight psychedelic drug
rock look at this is their album cover
this great record look at that artwork
yeah
such a great record man look at that
you could drop ass and just look at that
while you're listening
what's his name right now what's the kid
that goes to the laugh factory the young
kid who sings
and gets some bieber
you think justin bieber would do
something like this no
do you think he even understood
something like that i don't think you
know i never forget doing the longest
yard yeah okay and
first it comes on the movies
then it comes out like an hbo or
whatever then one day you open up a box
and it's 10 c dvds
and i'll never forget that i hope opened
up a [ __ ] thing
and it was just a dvd
and i turned it around there was a few
pictures from the movie
and that was it
and i remember going jesus christ what a
rip-off
what a rip-off society has become
where's the creativity where's the
booklet yeah where's the book where's
the booklet with the with the sticker
yeah it's something a sticker yeah a
package something nuts yeah a patch yep
people don't mind giving you 26.99 put a
[ __ ] sticker in there with the
[ __ ] some pictures and pictures from
off the field that player look at this
[ __ ] this is the european version so
this one's gatefold holy [ __ ] yeah
i'm staring at sabbath bloody sabbath
which is sitting right behind
marco which he has the european album we
have the american arm of course because
we're not hit by this [ __ ] savage
super great so you open it up this one
opens up
it has some
and this has them with a [ __ ] snake
or whatever the [ __ ] they got over here
and you were talking about yes yeah the
organist the guy's named rick wakeman
yeah he's really good friends with him
he plays right he plays on this and
technically likes to see do you know how
much they paid him how much a [ __ ]
beer yeah he we just went in there
jammed to savakadabra at the end all the
piano part all the moog synthesizers and
stuff like that and just jammed it's
like oh how much you want to get paid
just give me a beer and then they just
drink beer that's because that was
[ __ ] fun man
did you see
the induction of yes
yeah i spoke about it before again
one of the funniest [ __ ] things rick
waking don't [ __ ] around
rick wait hilarious did he put the cape
on
i loved yes i loved roundabout
you know i forget a lot of the songs i
like because it's been years in fact i'm
gonna go home and listen to fragile you
should yeah that early yes ma'am uh i
had mike keneally on the podcast from um
zappa and he came to see me at the
american comedy co and i got in his car
and he's playing
and i go hey man what the [ __ ] is this
it's great he goes oh it's a yes three
or whatever you know and i go this is
incredible i loved it and i never
listened to it when i was younger at all
i was like i'm not listening to that you
know now i'm like holy [ __ ] yes it's
great did you ever listen to this
oh yeah dude cause king crimson in the
court of the crimson king
so this was like yes but more
darker i remember there's all this stuff
and look they even did the whole
painting super pro they took time to
you know
paint all of this
the painters in the court of the crimson
king king unbelievable king crimson i
just saw them like two weeks like you i
saw roger waters and then the next day
saw king crimson they played at the
greek oh how was it it was [ __ ]
amazing they played you know stuff from
this stuff from from red lark's tongue
nice so i found that you guys were
having that conversation about pink
floyd yeah
about you know what would you rather see
and mark
mauricio i'm calling them every [ __ ]
name marco
poor kid mauricio said he'd rather what
are you giggling about [ __ ] i'm
not killing how you feeling my brother
fine see
you were panicking
crying no hummus we could we still got
time to put four or five more stars
now you're not good i can tell yeah you
seem normal tonight yeah you seem normal
like i don't even think you took
anything yeah what's going on it gives
you your sweating
you're moaning you go oh yeah why are
you upset tonight i'm not upset at all
you sure that conveyor about clowning uh
took it out of him yeah you know you
know we love you though you know i'm
always looking out for you cocktail yeah
no no no i'm just thinking about it
you're shitty you're you're hearing us
i'm just thinking about yep reviews no
i'm just taking that [ __ ] in and get you
guys later
mauricio where are you going now
where the hell are you going now oh i
got i got so much stuff to show you sit
down we'll show it later on
i said i'm still stuck on these [ __ ]
arms yeah for sure with autographs and
just
you know you showed up with ozzy
osbourne
posters exactly are you
um
i mean you have a fortune here i'm
obsessed with music look at all that
look do you think people do that now but
bands go out justin bieber does a
blacklight poster that looks that
[ __ ] amazing those are incredible
those are from the 80s i had to pay so
much money for those on ebay and i just
got three more iron maiden ones uh
yesterday
it's gonna be like posters those are so
vital grown up did you ever 30 years old
they're from uh that one came out it's
the year's on the bottom yeah
yeah three yeah that's 83.
yeah i've seen bruce lee once i know you
like bruce lee
they look [ __ ] great [ __ ] black
eyed persons i remember we'd get stoned
and then you have the purple light too
that you'd put on yeah
you took me back with those maurice i
forgot all about those [ __ ] things
how do you uh verify it like when you're
buying from ebay are you worried about
frauds or anything or i mean you could
tell i mean who else you know costs a
lot of money to make recreate one or not
not even just this but you must you must
spend a lot of time researching what you
want you you just you know you know
search on ebay blacklight posters just
scroll down newest ones and because they
get snatched up so quick just look at
the newest ones and then quickly just
buy them those are joey those are felt
they're like yeah
remember those yeah
incredible with those with anywhere that
you went where people had hair as long
as you yeah they had those in their
bedroom totally i had a friend that had
one of those bedrooms that he painted it
black
hilarious
he painted it black and he had that
thing that you put your head in and your
arms and they lock you in like medieval
oh yeah oh yeah a guillotine this was
way before people started
this was way before people dressing in
black and all this [ __ ] this guy was
normal but this was he had a noose
in this room this guy was out there
what are your buddies yeah legit i still
see him on facebook but he's all right
now
he had all these posters in his room so
when you go in his room
he never had a light in there
it pretty much this is what lit up the
room which made it creepy and it even
had a purple light and a red light you
never wanted to go to this house and you
were dripping
like i made that mistake with it before
they get water
we gotta run the [ __ ] out of there yeah
well those things are [ __ ] scary man
when you're all tuned up on something
and the guy and you're in a pitch black
room it's a small box like this and
those are lit up and you're on something
you're like what the [ __ ] well if you
really think about
the differences
in the music marketing of the 70s 60s
and midway of the
80s the the marketing was drugs
especially once the beatles grew long
hair and
beards and they started going to india
and taking trips
yeah let's face it that the allure was
you listen to music if you got high they
went to india yeah robbie shanker they
did i'm not lying to you they went to
india and learned how to play the
[ __ ] thing yeah they started taking
acid they wrote uh tomorrow's dream
[ __ ] what album is that amazing they
did that hit me what i was talking about
tomorrow's dream that's volume 4. no no
[ __ ] the beatles oh the beatles
knows yeah that's uh revolver revolver
yeah they went to india around the white
albums yeah so dear prudence and are you
[ __ ] detergent they went
i got this great these great demos of
them just playing in a living room uh
and and they got the sitars
and it's just a cassette of them and
they're talking past the bong you know
they're getting stoned and [ __ ] killer
man the whole thing was you know elton
john was
american pure at that time nobody really
knew that elton john was dressing up
like batman during the week and
banging some guy and they were both
writing lyrics while he had [ __ ]
you know stamina juice in his mouth you
know what i'm saying
who has the monkey juice in their mouth
i can't say that's what this is
you don't want to know what is it
juicy you know jamaica oh semen yeah
like what does dice call it banana milk
what a he tweeted something last night
he tweeted something last night that i
stared at and died
would you go see elton john he's playing
in i think he has a residency in las
vegas i'd love to see him you ever seen
him before you know what man when i was
a kid i didn't know the strength alan
john the year he took over new york
alan john was the first person i saw
lock up new york i was too young to
understand what he was doing
i fell in love with elton john over the
years
and uh from uh
the
your song yeah yeah this is your song
yeah from that i'm still standing oh
yeah 83 that's my ears elton john i had
to let him go
he started gaining some weight he wasn't
my
yeah
he just [ __ ] my world up but let me
tell you something bro sometimes i'm
driving and i'll hear philadelphia
freedom and i'll get tears in my eyes
rocket man rocket man uh the one uh
daniel from that movie daniel all that
[ __ ] is what i grew up on you know and
mauricio it's what you
you know uh
abw abc was the big station in new york
that was what you listen to here with
eleven because if you order button they
give you twenty five thousand dollars so
you all the button everywhere you reward
in your shower yeah i'm gonna tell you
wear it in the shower because you might
be looking through your window so i said
[ __ ] it i used to have it in the shower
but then you grow up and you go to wnew
you yeah but you still wear the button
right just okay [ __ ] them i wore that
button for five years nobody ever said
hello that's a genius that's a genius
marketing what's that right where
no no they don't like me
i found ice clay's tweet oh yeah what is
it it's the best and and it has multiple
layers
it's a happy fourth of july hope
everyone has a big fat ass to unload
their banana juice on tonight but then
even better if you scroll down has a
picture of nicki minaj and like really
skin tight yeah
america yoga pants yeah i see it with
her butt like just pointed towards you
it's a pretty good tweet it does
i love the dice he's been coming around
a lot lately that's what i heard yeah
yeah i saw him a couple weeks ago and uh
you know come in on a sunday and blaze a
set it's great to see him you know you
can't believe there were so many people
he said
every time i go down there there's
people crawling in the [ __ ] hallways
oh yeah it's [ __ ] he goes it's
tremendous it's like back in the 80s
were you there over the weekend
where were you
ice house you did ice house how was that
where the [ __ ] was i this weekend i
think you were there on one night
just one night though
maybe saturday was there saturday night
oh yeah awesome saturday thursday this
week is weird because it felt like we
just went came through a weekend almost
yeah
i knew this week wasn't going to be a
[ __ ] mort week anyway yeah yeah this
is a mort wait people aren't even coming
back some people said wonderful why
would they yeah i'll come back saturday
and go back to work tip top magoo monday
with a suntan take a vacation from the
vacation mauricio alvarado yeah hey joey
how did you get into mafia three the
video game because we audition i have
worked for those people for years you
should do voice acting your voice is
perfect for you
i got for everything my agent sent me
out every two weeks i'm over there on
[ __ ] uh
in burbank at a recording studio
recording this last one i have a feeling
i've been thinking about that so
hopefully from your mouth to god's limbs
i read for a cartoon i read for like a
mobster ah
i called back and i said tell him to lay
it again this way so
is that's a very tight family oh yeah
it's it's fort knox once you break in
you're in yeah once you do one now you
do them till you're 92. everybody knows
your voice now you're just going
everything they're right they write
something for you but until you're in
you're not really in you know what i'm
saying yeah a friend of mine who got me
into your comedy his name's gary he
actually has like one of those online
you know where you play the video games
right poorly played stream and yeah he
told me about it and he showed me the
video and and as soon as i saw it i was
like that's perfect that's joey and then
with the digital stuff that they could
do to you you know you don't have to
really
you know move or do that crazy stunts or
anything all everything's just digital
and then your voice every time i listen
to your voice i just think of you know a
lion king or something powerful like a
cartoon because your voice is that soon
yeah you're my i hope so i hope i get
this little episode
it's like 10 episodes oh that's awesome
so yeah
but yeah like i i really want to do
cartoon work too and
and if you know you get that you get the
tweets all the time you ought to do uh
cartoons but
that market
the big stars realized there's tons of
money in this and now they all went for
it yeah
before it was like guys like me or joey
or unknowns that had unique voices and
they'd go this is great and then you
became like bart man you know what i
mean bart simpson or whatever but now
the big stars are like wait i can just
show up in my sweatpants and and just go
into a studio and be like look out for
the man i said look
out listen first off
there's no more studios yeah first off
the guys that make
over like 150 grand and voiceovers maybe
like over 100 grand
they all have stuck studios now yep they
got an extra bedroom when they move in
they put a couple of panels in there
they put a little stream and they get
auditions constantly
so instead of even leaving the house
they lay their auditions
for you guys who don't know i've spoken
about this before
when i signed with this agent the first
thing they told me was to get this
and this times don't just call me out of
the blue
and uh
look at my wife [ __ ] came through
she remembered to check in for me she's
all right
she's a savage did you check in oh no
you don't yell
um
you know me don't i forget everything
i think maybe you guys might know all
those voice actors i'm going the next
day thank god yeah i'm like oh wait yeah
no i hate it i hate that
i love all that
stuff and i thought mafia 3 was very
interesting
but it's just too tight to get in but
once you're in you're in and i'm patient
i'm not going nowhere i don't smoke
cigarettes no more
was that mafia when you're dead out in
petaluma
the that game yes yeah yes when you gave
me directions that time yeah it's weird
bro when the sopranos were hot they
released they made shark tail
and deniro played the shark and big
[ __ ] played the other shark right and
word on the street was
his first residual check was like a half
a million dollars
wow those are sigil checks from those
kid movies when there's 80 in the movie
oh yeah oh when there's eight characters
in the movie yeah
and they just had one this week and they
did a hundred million the first weekend
what what's the new one it just came out
100 million this weekend the emoji movie
uh one of those yeah we've been telling
them they had a report today
about that they're struggling though
the cartoon ones all of them all of them
like they showed the last pirates of the
caribbean with that one made nationally
in this one
oh that's millions off doug last couple
the only
franchise movie that made money this
year is the one i mentioned earlier
galaxies of the universe oh yeah part
two that's the only one the rest of them
everybody's tanking
the mummy tanked
now they're waiting for planet of the
apes oh yeah that comes out next weekend
there's one more and they're all looking
like saying what the problem is
what's going on what happened with cars
and everything else we have too much
entertainment you know crystal lee a man
on fire i mean every week somebody has a
special i'm giving crystal a plug by the
way it's my brother
netflix
man on fire
came out last week great guy watch it
also jerry roaches comes out next month
a bunch of our friends comes on there
it's become like anything else it's just
an abundance of
specials now yeah there's an abundance
in fact i told somebody to make a call
for me call youtube red
let's see what they're paying for
[ __ ] specials
yeah
why not at least i asked absolutely why
not doug we're elevators you understand
when we gave seesaw a try
they don't want to show up on an
envelope everything dissipated now we
got to make a move we're like everybody
else now we're [ __ ] little guppies
out there now can you sell your uh the
cso and the special or do you get it
back
i have no [ __ ] idea right yeah once
it comes to all that [ __ ]
my wife has an attorney and she's in
contact with the people i don't even
want to know about it because i know i'm
going to shoot myself in the [ __ ]
head i know a couple gangsters that just
uh they just load up their specials on
uh sticks
and just you know once from like 10
years ago and just settlement shows
yeah hey here's my special from like 10
years ago you know
that's what you do yeah that's what you
do speaking of the mummy
is it was is there a band or a
like a musician
like brendan fraser who like seems to be
like a good person a nice guy or just
always gets like
the bad end of the movies the bad end of
deals well he just got cut out of the of
the mummy they just really know tom
cruise will be
doing this now the mommy oh he was in
the first mommy he was in the first few
of them yeah they wanted to remake their
remaking oh and they cut them out for
tom cruise yeah they cut them out they
cut the but brendan fraser always seems
to get like the
the raw end of the deal he never seems
to have a good like a good thing going
on he's old he's he's balding you've
seen his photos he's like oh you know
yeah
that's what happens when you're
good-lookingly when you come out here
looking good then you get old and you
lose your hair you're not that markable
no more like me i'm an ugly dude when i
got here and i'm still an ugly dude you
follow me saying but i'm looking smooth
i got the white hand now
i ain't going nowhere when you're good
looking when you're overly good looking
you're gonna go [ __ ] downhill yeah
yeah and those are the people that go oh
my god what happened to him what do you
think cheeseburgers alcohol cocaine yeah
[ __ ] you think happens to these
people people blowing smoke up your ass
that ages you too oh yeah you're the
greatest
i was curious um i'm you know i'm just
like a fan and stuff i'm not known i
don't know anything about the inner
comedy stuff but i was curious about
pablo francisco did you know him and
personally dear dear dear friend
i'm a big fan of his i love him with all
my heart
he's uh
he's one of those comics that
he's very generous he's helped a lot of
comedians
and i've been one of them he's had his
demons like i have
but uh
i'm just gonna tell you a little story
in 1997
i made my first trip to l.a
as a comic
i had been here as a civilian as a
criminal as a child
i had been here as many things
but now i showed up on the sunset strip
as a
comic
and part of my deal was i was staying
with a friend of mine
that i grew up with that brother-in-law
and he had been in a bunch of movies
he was
and what made him really special was he
had been
he would train with brandon lee
and he was on the set with brandon he
was visiting brandon louisiana when they
were shooting that wherever they were
shooting that
so uh
i stayed there for a few days and it was
right down the block from the lab
factory
i knew nothing about hollywood dog
nothing
no way was i gonna ask him to perform
i was just gonna go down there and see
who was on stage and sit and watch and
i'd pay for the two drink cover
and i walked up there as i walked up
there
somebody i knew from seattle was
performing there like somebody that
was from seattle and moved that way
and they said come on come in with me
i'll give you a chair i'll get your
water
and it was monday night latinos night
you couldn't breathe now i know i have
factory
you cannot be used to go to the lab
factory uh no okay yeah when you've been
to the left factory lane they got 82
people yeah i'm talking about people
hanging from the rafters that's why they
had to put the glass up
they would have the tv room latino night
was the laugh factories busiest [ __ ]
night
in the late 90s
there was a line around the corner years
later they started chocolate sundae
but to get to the story i get on i get
in there i sit in the back you cannot
breathe
two thousand mexicans at the [ __ ]
laugh factory howard
who was on stage johnny sanchez um
the kid that died freddie soda
[ __ ] palm blowing up there in the
height of seinfeld
the height of seinfeld
and did seinfeld in spanish
i i i wanted to just go home and crawl
on the [ __ ] rock
he did each character
in spanish how they would sound not only
in english
never mind impersonating somebody in
english yeah but that's how talented
pablo francisco really is
yeah the reason i bring him up was in
high school like 2005
six seven
people my friends would share his bits
and pieces tremendous it was the
funniest thing i've ever seen oh my god
still is and but yeah now that i'm older
now when i you know i'm you know i see
you having a podcast oh i could go see
joey i could go see dean at the comedy
store and then i'm always like well what
about pablo like i've never seen him do
a show over here in l.a or i've never
heard of anything i think pablo did
three or four podcasts and
they were all probably very fidgety
[Music]
what's going on guys this is great
this is phenomenal pablo so do you
where'd you start coming
you know
i heard like
one time he walked out of a podcast i'm
not
i'd love to get him on if he wanted to
be candid and
talk about his career here in l.a he'd
be [ __ ] tremendous yeah because he
was in mad tv tremendous he was
tremendous he was doing his bits on that
yeah no when i got here pablo was
rocking
and [ __ ] rolling but pablo got huge
on the road
huge on the road you know
he was [ __ ] pretty big you know when
i first got his choice lopez was huge on
the road
pablo uh
bobby slayton probably saying the pit
bull
uh they checked wendy lieben that runs a
night there was a couple of people that
were [ __ ] ripping it up here in town
eddie griffin oh yeah the store was
ripping it up on the road you know
and it all goes but pablo's still
consistent
he still goes out there you know
i don't know why he hasn't taped the
special i mean god knows what's on his
mind
last time i saw him he was healthy
and i love him more than ever man
yeah i saw him at the store about a year
ago
he came down and did some showing
yeah yeah yeah that's right yeah that's
great
crushed it
how do you uh feel about paul mooney
showing up because didn't he have like
health problems or something there was
like he went on a show i think arsenio
he went on arsenio but he was very
you know loopy or just like off oh and
then i heard that yeah i heard
yeah
i guarantee he needs money you know
and
he's doing like a comedy heroes type
tour
you know he did great at the store he
sold out those are 50 dollar tickets my
friend
450 of those but
who knows who's handling these toys did
he was it new material or older i
couldn't even they were sold out i stood
down i just wanted to see what he looked
like yeah see what his candidate was
going to be like and i saw they sat him
down
so i knew it wasn't and just to see him
on stage
and to think about
what he used to do when the original
room was good enough for me
i don't know if he's going to do a tour
i don't know what else he's going to do
whatever he's going to do i wish him
well what's up papa
you're all right you got spots you're on
fire it's time to do four more stars lee
i'm gonna break the record start up lee
i know it's monday night wait what's the
most stars you ever took three thousand
three thousand miles tell them what you
took how many stars was that though
fifteen
fifteen stars was that the time i was
here and you vomited on your shirt no
that was when i did the [ __ ] answer
that's when we did the liquid there yeah
yeah um
well how much how many milligrams you do
tonight i don't know what did we do
you did four and five
okay
no we need more we did six and five
six one we did three stars all right so
six
they did the chocolate right i did two
chocolate bars
and look you survived it was he's doing
fine that's right you're looking
beautiful yeah let's do two more stars
nothing expect
fourth of july we're going to see larry
star spangled bam you're gonna go to
vegas you're staying in a different
hotel you will get your undisclosed
location lee you going to vegas he's
going to vegas all right
are you kicked out of that place someone
said no he's banned for life what
happened
you can't say it because they're legal
all right oh man don't worry about what
he did what are you writing the [ __ ]
book what's the questions
[ __ ] questions invite them on your
podcast
somebody no i'm just saying someone
threw it in the tweet they you know they
said oh joey and dean all right is lee
still 86 for a lot of 86 for life but
don't worry my number i made some calls
all right we got [ __ ] dinero to call
the riviera yeah over there
what do you got there my bro look at
this one here that's this one so this is
one this is the reason why people
thought black sabbath was satanic so
they recorded their album in you know
europe and england so under the label
vertigo so that you know these vertical
albums are very sought after you know
they say the pressing's really good and
stuff like that so vertigo was the one
who was in charge of doing the album
cover and doing you know everything the
band just made the music recorded it
send it off that's it
but this is what they did on the inside
cover
they put the upside down cross
so people see this
black sabbath and they immediately put
it the band was satanic and that's just
some art dude doing it wasn't even the
band's theory yeah and there's even a
story that tony homey was on stage and
the guy went at him with a knife he was
going to stab him but you know his
security guards went on stage and
this could be one of the scariest covers
of all time joey right
i've looked at that for hours while i
was tripping one night and it destroyed
me looking at that house the green
coming up on the house
it's a [ __ ] beautiful cup what they
did
in those years recovers the photography
was brilliant it gave you an insight
of what you were about to listen to
and emotion never mind [ __ ] we got to
work on an album we also got to work on
the [ __ ] cover to take them there
that's why you look at those five pink
floyd albums ah
and you think to yourself what were they
thinking
first of all i want the drug they were
doing
it wasn't adderall it wasn't oh my god
they're bipolar all of them were [ __ ]
like
yeah all of them had problems to write
that type of [ __ ] music back to the
argument
i was mad at roger waters for years
the same
lee thinks i [ __ ] with him when i tell
him about different things that i do he
giggles
i have always been one of those people
like when tom
what's his name what's his [ __ ] guy
coach phillips captain phillips tom
hanks tom hanks cried when he got the
academy award yeah i wouldn't watch his
that's why i told tonight
i've never seen run forrest run oh yeah
first game i got pissed at him for
[ __ ] couple years for crying marlon
brando won the academy award he didn't
cry
you know just [ __ ] like that i get
pissed off at people
for personal [ __ ] reasons
personal and hidden reasons he doesn't
tell anybody yeah they'll say that
why don't you like tom hanks i'm running
your business no tom hanks he cried when
he got the award so you wrote him off
yeah
[ __ ] that [ __ ] proof the most amazing
actors ever oh he showed emotion hello
[ __ ] this guy in philadelphia i'm never
watching him again cry baby
i forgot what the [ __ ] i was gonna tell
you what the [ __ ] are we talking about
you had a problem with roger waters yeah
i had a big problem roger was the same
way i have a problem with sting
they broke up on the best bands
they broke up their own thing because of
their ego
well do you know the story about why the
wall was created right because they
wanted they didn't want it they didn't
want it he hated the audience he hated
the audience he's spat at once he's a
very
sanate quad type of dude
you know what bro if you got anti-social
[ __ ] problems
then just let people know but don't be a
[ __ ] hell let's build a wall i'm
paying to come to [ __ ] see you yeah
yeah
that's why you gotta love ace freely but
then they know they wasted that money
i want to take a rocket yeah well you
know who's worse it's richie blackmore
the stories oh my god was mine deal
hated him oh bro everybody [ __ ] hates
him that's why he never there's
the video the documentary about him it's
all him and his wife kind of making the
documentary and you could see him just
twisting his stories he gets [ __ ] up
in that video you should really watch it
he talks about [ __ ] he looks so [ __ ]
spooky yeah yeah joey was talking about
that last time
his stomach is
his mess his mustache
it's [ __ ] strainer core he always
always a [ __ ] i went to see him like
once or twice
but he's always been a [ __ ] you
could tell from the [ __ ] audience you
know number one he never had a second
like everybody always left
when they're happy and they're making
money they're writing good music
and they [ __ ] stick around for four
or five albums
him i don't know
like santana would have been huge if he
would have got a permanent singer yeah i
love santana you know me dog i'm into
all that [ __ ] but sometimes i sit there
like i took them till 19 [ __ ] 99 with
the singer from [ __ ] matchbox 20
matchbox 20 to really really really
breakthrough you know he could have
broken through in the 60s
with the same i always feel that a
consistent singer
and a consistent guitar player is
maya and there you go and they
didn't parties or something's broken
i feel that it's really consistent you
know he never had that
there's a bunch of guys that never had
a [ __ ] guitar player for even billy
idol i had what's his name yeah steve
stevens for how many years that was the
secret
santana never had the same singer
well you know santana like that whole
era the earlier with greg raleigh
singing you know him and neil shawn and
the drummer and
they just leave and start journey you
know but and that was the total early
sound of santana to me is that great
greg raleigh voice you know like a black
magic woman but he wasn't a front man he
was over there on the b3 so there's no
front man really so now the front man
sells
and navigates the show and then you
don't see them like that i've always how
many men look at we've discussed it
before
one of the greatest front men but
horrible singers of our [ __ ] time
it's the guy from molly crew vince nail
horrible front man
horrible i'll tell you who else i
[ __ ] despise kk darwin i don't like
all that jumping up and down just play
the [ __ ] music and stop jumping up
you're not even doing nothing you're not
even doing that look at glenn tipton
sweating bullets over there his wing is
twisted and over here you're making all
these noises
and all these white kids are jumping up
and down sit down you [ __ ] before i
smack it i hated all those types i like
people with that's why i really always
enjoyed
the sewing maze the same so good because
i could see the power individual power
each of them there was nothing to
detract you
from the pure power that was led
zeppelin
each guy was a master
unbelievable john paul together yeah the
fluidity the whole [ __ ] thing even
live
they took you into different dimensions
every night what did you think of that
my friend led zeppelin yeah yeah you
know
you know
i like led zeppelin but i prefer sabbath
and nothing wrong with that nothing
wrong
you know it's just there's certain bands
yeah that's one of the bands that just i
listen to them and i get you know why
they're popular and stuff like that but
then i also heard the
there's audio recording of them where
they go track by track of that first
album they go through all the songs that
they kind of ripped off with all these
old blues musicians there's even a
documentary about it no i've seen all
that yeah yeah so that's kind of you
know but i i understand we all have one
yeah yeah
i get them but i prefer you know others
you know what though what happened man
like with me like i go years where i
don't i can't stand a band like growing
up i was like i hate pink floyd man
they're just stoner rock you know it's
just burn out rock burn that's all i
ever thought and then one day
boom it hits me and i go man i love pink
floyd and now i listen to them like
every day for 25 30 years you know you
put them on it's like oh animals i go
i'll play animals for a month it's crazy
because for me and a lot of people are
gonna get mad by me saying this i bought
dark side of the moon
and i thought dark side of the moon was
tremendous i really did
but when i
got a hold of animals which i never knew
existed i'm not going to tell you it was
you know in those days it wasn't like
you could open up the computer wikipedia
yeah
pink floyd look at that back catalog you
had to actually go to the record store
and then go and then pull them out and
look through the year and try to
but i heard animals
i went over to my friends that shed
and i heard dogs
and i was like what is this and he goes
this is painful and i'm like are you
from the dark side of the moon pink boy
yeah he was like yeah and
that was it i went and got that and the
following saturday
wish you were here and the following
saturday hunger monger
oh yeah oh my god yeah you know it was
justified you would have loved the roger
waters yeah no i know there was two sets
first set in the second set so in the
first set or in the second set you just
see this uh projector just going right
in the middle of staple center then it
goes up and then you know the album
cover with the chimney that just like
like it looks like it's building up
chimney comes up there's smoke real
smoke they start playing dogs
and then the pig just starts flying
around it's uh it was amazing it's
amazing
this pink floyd is unbelievable
what's the matter with us you know this
fury laughs fearless yeah echoes
no no tremendous cool
nothing um
what's the album that goes with the
wizard of oz yeah
yeah i was just thinking about my summer
camp when i was in like
sixth grades maybe i was like 11 or 12.
i did that i watched that but obviously
very like stone cold sober yeah so like
it was that this weekend this [ __ ] it
didn't make any sense like you might do
a periscope of eating
2 000 milligrams and sitting there
playing that describing what's going on
with you emotionally and physically at
the time
one time you want to call 911
was some good weed today man oh that
little [ __ ] around it was good
with the best it was just [ __ ]
perfect my [ __ ] nick from the pizza
place the best what was it called again
it's called run your business that's not
the question no no i'm just i wanna know
it's a solid diesel saturday's all right
it's good joey
were you ever into genesis with peter
gabriel i wasn't the genesis with peter
gabriel and genesis without peter
gabriel this one's apparently all about
new york city this whole album is his
last album with peter gabriel the whole
thing is a co as a concept album about a
puerto rican kid in new york city
lambs lie down on broadway it's one of
their best albums i don't know if you
ever heard it before such a great logo
right
my god [ __ ] peter gabriel with
genesis was uh
like that he did theater he'd he would
dress up as the fox and do the whole
thing totally
music was complete you know
it's weird to see that uh what's going
on with music live music yeah
i'm happy that you two guys are holding
the torch out there hey
what's your next big show my brother uh
that the eagles one that
california west yeah the one with i want
to see steely dano have a big steely
dancer oh my god i saw them at the
hollywood bowl they played original
lineup yeah both guys yeah
yeah donald trump i saw that too
they did fireworks doing bodhisattva
yeah amazing i see your picture yeah i
keep it with you
yeah
cocaine jazz dude right oh my god it's
the best man i love that and they didn't
tour when they were huge in the 70s they
didn't tour they were just a studio band
so when they finally did tour and i went
and saw them and they they opened up
with like hey 19 you're just going like
oh my god they sound just like the
record exact
you know the singer's so wacky up there
man the keyboard guy uh you know what's
his name you got doc walter and then
donald fagan is playing the flying v's
and [ __ ] that was awesome they played
asia asia's my favorite album of theirs
and they played stuff from that yeah
they sound great like all these bands
are just coming out they're doing tours
big tours a lot of bands are uh joining
together because you know if they go up
by their own they can't you know really
sell out like hall of notes or joining
up with tears for fears yeah that's how
we're playing at the staples center that
one's going to be great uh there's going
to be a yes festival with yes todd
rundgren carl palmer from emerson
lincoln palmer the drummer
soon be playing at the microsoft theater
there's a bunch of stuff that's coming
out a lot of great stuff uh metal
there's a argentinian band i think
called rata blanca
really classic heavy metal stuff slayer
mega death scorpions are playing we
gotta go to scorpions joey what do you
think let's go
get me the date let me ask you something
where can people see your work brother
uh if you go on instagram it's switch
i'm hung you [ __ ] tony naomi pictures
i hung him up yeah thank you yeah
beautiful [ __ ] man really really
beautiful [ __ ] yeah the instagram is
switch mag mx and you can see all the
photos so i have photos of the iron
maiden show that i just want to go see a
photos of corn totally good switch mag
mx so m-a-g m-a is an apple yeah so it's
like switch magazine mx so switch mag mx
awesome man photos are great too
really good thank you yeah the iron
maiden one are you shooting film or
digital digital film you guys remember
it's a fuji film it's a small little uh
point-and-shoot type of camera you guys
were talking about you know using old
film now it's like thirty dollars oh
yeah yeah are you using your photo are
you using photoshop
no you use lightroom just like this
but uh so are you gonna go with joey to
like a couple shows do you i hear he's
kind of difficult to go to shows with
now he's just kind of like
is that true
i'm always inviting him but he's you
know i know he has got a family
it's not difficult i think
i think when you look at someone like
joey and myself uh it's easier for me
because i have the motorcycle and i just
ride right up park and go in but
you know when you're
when you've seen like thousands of shows
and and then you a lot of times when you
go
and i i said this recently on my podcast
and i say it uh and i am starting to
mean it other than the dead
if i've seen the band
more than twice
i'm not going to go see him anymore
because
when i go see a band like let's say
maiden
and i'm there for the tenth time seeing
maiden i go you know i saw maiden
on the on the number of the beast tour
twice i saw him on the power slave i saw
him on the somewhere in time tour i saw
you know and then i started thinking i
saw this band when they're at the
incredible hyatt that's why i try to go
see new bands now like gretavon fleets
coming next week to the viper room and
i'm so fired up to see that like i was
back when i was discovered a band like
def leppard i was fired up to see that
well the thing i have with newer bands
is i don't i try i don't go after new
bands i don't want to listen to bands
and here's why because i feel like a lot
of new bands try to do old stuff right
that older bands used to do so then my
mind i'm like well why should i listen
to this new band that's why i sound like
a shitty you know that's a wise move
i'll go see the original stuff yeah what
i'm saying with me is i've seen the
original stuff so much that when i'm
standing there and they bust into you
know
uh you know the trooper
of course i love it but i've seen it 80
times
so i'm like i need to see some new stuff
so these there's some new bands
out there that are killing it man
gorgira wow you like them yeah i think
they play with slayer yeah
unbelievable gorgira and uh greta von
fleet loving them and oh
i just got turned onto this band
yesterday called uh if you're into punk
rock they're called
idols
and it's uh it's pretty insane this band
so check that out you know but yeah oh
here it is right here
idols a-d-l-e-s
brutalism this record joey i just got
turned on yesterday new band out of the
uk
sound like [ __ ]
sound like
like sex pistols
just a punch in the face man let me ask
you something points in the face
mauricio
you wanted to talk about a theater or
something you were doing
a theater like all the stuff you had or
something
oh yeah
um i'm working with this guy named
caitlyn he was in a band called hyrax
yeah like this old thrash band so with
the reason i have those posters is we go
to bars we set them up we make it look
like a you know an 80s room yeah and we
basically just play heavy metal you know
saturday nights and just have guest djs
so i'm gonna have uh the guy from
testament and dark angel the drummer
gene hoagland oh yeah he's great trying
to get a guy from uh
testament exodus so basically what i
want to do is i want to get people to
come out hang out at a bar listen to
heavy metal music listen to you know
pink floors stuff like this you know
classic stuff that people don't usually
listen to you know on the radio or you
know i want to what i basically want to
do is i want to turn people on a new
music because there's a lot of music
that fill in the cracks yeah there's
pink floyd zeppelin sabbath but then
there's also all those you know smaller
bands that kind of fell through the
crack smaller songs
really kick-ass songs that just people
have never heard because you know how
are you going to find it you know you
got to have somebody to say hey i've
listened to thousands of records if you
like sabbath here are 10 other bands
that sound like sabbath you like stuff
like master reality here's some bands
that sound like master reality if you
like more you know
genesis like this era this you know i'm
obsessed with records i'm obsessed with
music i
collect vinyl what i have in my room is
all vintage gear yeah what gear you got
i got like um
uh what is it one of those uh
i got
poke audio speakers i got like 10 of
them i got sub i got like three
subwoofers i got you know basically i
have a wall of speakers
all of records all vinyl you know the
best you know hardware i'm a bit of a
nerd about that stuff but yeah you know
i get into the music i get into the
theater i get into the whole thing about
it where can they see the dates that you
promote these things if you follow us on
switch mag mx all the dates are on there
i always post dates for new uh new
concerts new dates and then my stuff as
well you know you'll see it on there you
into the dead
into the grateful dinner i like the
grateful dead freaking great man yeah i
like you know the funkier stuff that he
did with summit citibank city field the
new mets
stadium you'd like that place it's clean
man like nice small ballpark they came
in there and just crushed it last
saturday
crushed it you know i wanted to get you
two guys together because i knew it
would be a
a very very very interesting podcast man
yeah he and i talked nonstop in the
parking lot no this is great so thank
you mauricio thank you for coming on i
thought you'd be a great guest
and you've always been a great young man
you know i love you to that
we're going to be in vegas together i
can't wait to thank you for you're going
to be in detroit when on i'm doing next
weekend with bill burke rapids two
nights and then i'm headlining one night
in detroit on sunday the 16th at a rock
club called smalls and uh i want
everybody to come out detroit represent
man that'd be great
thank you brother for coming on oh
thanks for having me see you in vegas
gonna keep food and [ __ ] yeah oh yeah
what are we gonna have don't worry about
nothing okay you don't need seafood i
love it where do you kill me you could
eat seafood yeah i couldn't eat it clams
yeah shrimp cocktails yeah
uh no clam chowder's got sugar in it all
right i still got a little bit of it
maybe a cup but yeah saltine you know we
got i got your back
well we shall see you at the store you
know keep inviting me to these events
sure eventually one day i'm going to go
let's [ __ ] do this tony bennett i'm
waiting on those tickets if you want to
go okay what day is that i think it's
13th and 14th of july
we're going to scorpions
that's next week you'll be out yeah
that's the next [ __ ] week there you
go
lisa yeah you're right over there you're
over there giggling having a good
[ __ ] time
huh
i know you're leaving here i got over on
joey
tonight i only ate two chocolate bars
and three stars i don't even think he
ate him i know he don't i don't think i
i i thought out of the corn of my eyes
to see him do something with the
chocolate yeah it's his normal he's my
little brother yeah he's normal i have
really good health insurance so i
installed something so i just have a
filter system i'm gonna go shoot it all
out real quick let me tell you something
i wanted the mp just now i gotta piss
let me tell you something my piece
smells so bad i won't even
my enemies suck my dick you understand
me that's how much you stunk when i
[ __ ] beaten it but you people don't
need to know this you don't need to know
if you're pink if your [ __ ] piece
thinks you're over 50
it's time for you to get hello tushy
hello toshi works as a is a portable
bidet but they that you install in your
bathroom right there ping pang tune
nobody gets their feelings
you take a little poop you saw your
breath hit the button
and next thing you know water sprinkling
your [ __ ] and you're like why do i
need a bidet why because first of all
you're a filthy [ __ ] animal
some of you people leave the house at
seven in the morning you don't wash it
you get back home do you have any idea
what it smells like between your legs do
you ever go home at night and step in
between your ball sack and your [ __ ]
and say to yourself what if i would have
bumped into a stranger
he wouldn't be able to eat my [ __ ] he
would [ __ ] pass out from the stench
you don't need that that's why you need
hellotushy.com in your bathroom right
now
why joey why
eliminates a thousand things hemorrhoids
swamp ass
germs you don't need little diseases and
it keeps your vag clean it keeps your
helmet [ __ ] clean it keeps everything
[ __ ] clean you understand me that's
why it's the summertime
if you're [ __ ] muffler ain't clean
what happens if you get invited to a
[ __ ] catholic orgy
what happens what happens you show up at
the vatican you wanted to go eat
spaghetti and meatballs but you bump
into [ __ ] six priests dressed up like
elvis what are you gonna do
at least your muffler's clean you know
what i'm saying you can take it up
go to hellotushy.com
we got a 90-day money-back guarantee but
you're going to love i'm going to
promise you you're going to love
hellotischee.com
why because i said so lee how much do
you enjoy yellowtushy i love it i can't
count on let's do dick
i can count on lena put the podcast up
on the [ __ ] extreme you could take
lee surround him with sharks and he'll
still put the podcast up why because he
knows i love him
i can count on lee for anything else in
the world
except [ __ ] he don't want to do
nothing
but i'll tell you what i can count on
lean
i know lee washes his ass three to four
times a day with hello tushy you know
why because he loves it once you try
hello
it's like black [ __ ] once you go blank
you don't go back you understand me
talently
once you go tushy
you're falling the pushy you know what
i'm saying it's all about keeping that
muffler clean
90 day money back guarantee go to
hellotushing.com take a look at the shed
go to hellotushy.com
no but just tell them go hello to
cushy.com right now slash church and
look at the big day portable you're
going to love it you understand me why
mess around
save a tree
save a [ __ ] tree how many [ __ ]
rows of toilet paper you gonna use to
wipe that [ __ ] muffler hole of yours
you know how many [ __ ] trees they're
killing right now because you want to
take a [ __ ] and comfort knock it off
hellotushy.com right now
slash church
get 10 off you know i love you
[ __ ] number two honey.com solid
on it
solid the best supplements in the
[ __ ] market that's why i love
them
shroom tech i live on that [ __ ] and i'm
still a fat [ __ ]
but can you imagine if i wasn't taking
the shroom tech
i could only roll one [ __ ] minute i'm
rolling two and a half three minutes
depending when i had a protein shake or
not
go to honor.com right now all right look
at the great selection of supplements
from the hem forced chocolate protein
which is cocoa whatever the [ __ ] they
call it cacao i don't know what the [ __ ]
think about it i call it chocolate the
right knock off this [ __ ]
to the hell to the to the hem force acai
vanilla which is very delicious to the
mcp oil i mean listen just go to
honor.com right now if you see something
you like go to the box and press in
church bam
get yourself ten percent off the vig and
it gets delivered to your house i love
you [ __ ] have a great week
weekend we'll see you [ __ ] monday
morning tip top magoo ready to rock you
understand me have a great weekend we
love you i want to thank mauricio
alvarado what are you nuts i want to
thank my main man
dean delrissie and i want to switch up
to yes roundabout scratch the song
that's there let's go to yes roundabout
we talked about yes i want to give you a
piece of my youth you know why because
that's the type of [ __ ] uncle
joey is
i want to leave you what i [ __ ] the
first song i lost my mind i smoked dope
i did [ __ ] the three pipe bazooka
this was the song that pushed me over
the top have a great weekend don't
forget
this weekend
vegas next weekend st louis philadelphia
don't [ __ ] around see you at the borgata
july 29th have a great weekend bye-bye
[Music]
[Music]
um
is
oh
is
here
you